foreign
all right
I think I suggested
questions
for her
until 10 4 procedure and I proceeded to
ask questions myself offer
fact permission had been given to
covid-19 free families for justice
to ask questions themselves so I
apologize I
feel like I'm treating them in their
Turf and I asked the questions myself
and in relation to Mr Osborne
he said that no court participant group
had sought to ask questions of mistrals
on the correct position in fact is that
one particular group again Improvement
19 revamps Justice had sought permission
to ask questions of Israel's permission
had actually been declined
thank you good morning my lady I call
Sir Mark walport
I do solemnly
sincerely and truly
declare and affirm
that the evidence I shall give
it should be the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth
thank you so mark thank you for the
assistance that you've given so far to
the inquiry I know that you have
provided a full and very helpful witness
statement and thank you for coming to
give evidence today please keep your
voice up and address your answers into
the microphone so that the stenographer
can hear for the transcript we will take
a break during the course of your
evidence but if at any time before that
you require a break just say so and we
will do that
may we bring up on screen please
inq00014707
um could we look at the second page
please this is your witness statement
samark and if we go to page 49 we can
see that you have signed it
although your signature has been
redacted and that you've confirmed under
the statement of truth that you believe
the fact stated in the witness statement
to be true is that right that's correct
thank you very much we can take that
down
dealing first of all then with your
background so far as it's relevant to
this inquiry you're a fellow of the
Royal College of Physicians a retired
fellow of the Royal College of
Pathologists and an honorary fellow of
the Royal College of Pediatrics and
child health you're a fellow of the
Academy of Medical sciences and a fellow
council member and Trustee of the Royal
Society and an honorary fellow of the
Royals Society of Edinburgh you have
extensive experience of strategy and
policy development the provision of
science advice to government the funding
and catalysts of re research crisis
management and organizational leadership
and you were director of the welcome
trust from 2003 to 2013.
from 2013 to 2017 you were the
government Chief Scientific Advisor
and from 2017 to 2020 you were the
founding Chief Executive Officer of ukri
that's United Kingdom research and
innovation
you were a member of the prime
minister's Council for Science and
Technology CST and co-chair during your
time as
gcsa and you continued to extend the CST
in your role as CEO of the ukri until
2020. whilst you were the government
Chief Scientific Advisor you were
responsible for running go science
ensuring that the Prime Minister and
cabinet received the scientific advice
that they needed and you drove
systematic improvements across the
government in relation to how science is
used and we will turn to that during the
course of your evidence
so please explain to us Sir Mark what is
entailed in the role of government Chief
Scientific Advisor okay thank you
so the job of the government Chief
Scientific Advisor is very broadly drawn
it is essentially to advise the Prime
Minister and the government on all
aspects of science engineering and
technology for the whole breadth of
government policy
um and um of course that is not because
the government Chief Scientific Advisor
has expertise on all of those matters
and in fact you know at some level it is
incidental that I am medically qualified
and so have some background in the
topics but nevertheless my job was to
work across the whole of government and
there are extensive mechanisms of
science advice which the gcsa plays a
role in coordinating so firstly I was
supported by the government office of
science yes secondly each government
department has its own CSA not all of
them but many of them and part of the
work over the last 10 years or more has
been to increase the number of Chief
scientific advisors embedded with the uh
those are appointed by the individual
government department and are usually at
a direct or a Direct General level yes
and so my role was as a permanent
secretary reporting to the cabinet
secretary but with direct access to the
Prime Minister and the government so
there's the network of Chief scientific
advisors uh part of the job was also to
be head of the government science and
engineering profession and there are
many thousands of scientists and
Engineers working in many roles across
government
there are many advisory committees and
we'll talk I'm sure more about some of
the advisory committees in relation to
coronavirus there are also arms link
bodies bodies like the meteorological
office the environment agency the health
Protection Agency as was public health
thing it became so there's a ray of
advisory committees
and the job was a mixture of
providing advice in emergencies which is
obviously an important topic for this
inquiry but also it involved Horizon
scanning and foresight work so the
government Horizon scanning unit sat in
government office science working
closely with others and so the range of
work was was very large indeed right
well it sounds as if it was very large
indeed
um you speak very quickly Sir Mark sorry
could I invite you during the course of
evidence just to slow down a little bit
because for the purposes of the
sonographer thank you I'd like to focus
on on three aspects of the role please
and you set these out in paragraph 15 of
your witness statement the first it is
this that as as the chief Scientific
Advisor you
um you were supportive of the Civil
contingencies Secretariat in the
development and updating of the national
risk assessment can you explain to us
some more what your role was in relation
to the National risk assessment well
um so the natural risk assessment which
first of all covers uh both malicious
threats and natural hazards yes
um science advice is relevant to many of
those and so the job wasn't as it were
to have any overall responsibility for
the NRA the nrr itself but to provide
make sure that there is relevant science
advice wherever it is possible and that
again wasn't done by the gcsa and the
government officer science alone it was
done with the support of each of the
csas for the relevant government
Department who would work within their
Department
firstly to make sure that risks where
science was involved were identified for
the NRA and secondly to look at their
input but they were not there as it were
in the National risk register risk
assessment is a pan government document
right okay so it was just to play a part
in in the whole of the um of the um
organization of that
um did you also
play a role in the preparedness
exercises that we have heard that the
government carried out from time to time
yes so
um it's I would argue one of the
strengths of the UK system that there is
a hard-wired mechanism to provide
scientific input wherever it's
appropriate by science I mean that in
the broader sense so I would include
engineering technology and for example
the social Behavioral Sciences where
that was relevant as well
um and so
um the the CSA would act as a
it's a pseudoscientific transmission
mechanism it goes back to my point that
the gcsa is not expert on everything yes
but the job of the gcsa is to try and
find the researchers the scientists who
are relevant and effectively transmit
that advice to government thank you um
and so yes the job did involve attending
um both practice exercises but also
Cobra when it involved a scientifically
relevant issue yes because the the third
main role that I wanted to focus on is
that when an incident occurs it's a it's
a big part of your role to be engaged in
the response to an actual emergency
correct yeah all right thank you
um
tell us a little bit more please sir
Mark about go science and how that
interacts with government departments
and provides advice in the way that it
does well I mean so firstly go science
um has um it's a relatively small office
overall I mean it was about 60 or 70
people and I was involved and there is a
group in go so to specifically work on
questions of resilience so on the risk
registered but they're all there was
also a group that were responsible for
example for Horizon scanning and
foresight work there was another group
that worked with the science and
engineering professions as a whole the
government Chief scientist was a um
there were a group of analysts across
government and the two scientists was a
representative on that group
um so basically it acted as the
mechanism and and obviously that we
convened uh two scientific advisors on
an informal basis every Wednesday
morning so we would all meet as a group
thank you
um
there is a distinction isn't there
between the provision to government of
scientific advice at the position of
policy advice and also political
decision making and um I'd like to to
seek your view please sir mark on the
limitations of scientific advice within
those three areas and and yet how it
fits within policy advice and political
decision making yes
question I think so
um the ultimate policy makers are the
government the ministers they are the
people that make the policy and they
I would argue look through three lenses
when they're deciding on policy so the
first question is what do I know about X
or Y and that is the lens of evidence
yes and that is where scientific advice
is very important
the second lens they look through is if
I make a policy is it deliverable
because people are always coming up with
great ideas for policy which are utterly
undeliverable so there is a practical
question about whether the policy is
deliverable or not and the third lens
they look through is the lens of their
political personal values
and so when they make policy they are
integrating those three things
um and people used to quite often say
you know why did they take any notice of
the science well the answer is that
actually the science is part of the
story yes and at the end of the days
values sometimes Trump uh the evidence
um I would say that is less an issue
when it comes to a volcano uh or
something like that but nevertheless
those are the three lenses that the
policy maker looks through and the the
the the job of the Scientific Advisor in
some ways is much easier than the job of
the policy maker
Principles of Scientific advice as you
set out in your witness statement are
threefold clear roles and
responsibilities
Independence and transparency and
openness are any one of those three more
important than the other
um I don't think so I think they're all
equally important I mean I think if
you're uh if you're not transparent then
it's not you're not communicating
properly um and I I think also an
important part is to advise on
uncertainty right and that is
particularly important in many
emerging issues and a pandemic is a good
example of that that in a pandemic it is
a new organism and therefore at the
start of it you may know very little
about it and so part of the job of a
Scientific Advisor is to communicate
uncertainty as much as it is to say what
we know so it's what we know what we
don't know and having the confidence to
do that and yes
could we display please inq
zero zero zero two zero four zero one
four this is our rather complicated uh
yes um wiring diagram yes diagram
um I want to use this please to focus in
on certain scientific advisory
committees and invite you so Mark please
to provide the inquiry with some
explanation of what they are there for
how they work and and who we might
expect to see in each of them yes well I
mean my first comment is that the the
wiring diagram itself is sort of most of
government yes um and uh I think from my
perspective there is actually a fairly
clear hardwired mechanism for scientific
advice which is that if you look at the
role of the government Chief Scientific
Advisor and in a in many emergencies
um the sage committee which we'll come
on to I'm sure yes would be chaired
principally by the gcsa but co-chaired
where relevant by the relevant CSA from
the government Department the CMO who is
an extremely figure a senior figure in
government a very old established office
actually uh typically co-chairs Health
emergencies with the gcsa and uh but
when it comes to COBRA and both may end
up there actually my job was to act as
that transmission mechanism and then I
was advised by the scientific Advisory
Group for emergencies which of course is
not a standing committee it's a
committee which is bespoke to the nature
of the emergency and Sage itself
is that fed into by either
committed set up specifically for the
purpose so expert advisory subcommitters
or by relevant standing committees and
so what you have and so I think it's
actually a relatively clean structure
which works well so there is no sciences
and then there are a series of uh
committees bodies in and around the
Department of Health and Social care
these are masses of course that are
familiar to you but yes but no I I
forgive me
um it's my fault I should have picked up
on that so can we just go back just
because I think there was some over
speaking as well you said Sir Mark it
was a relatively appealing structure
um this black will interrupted and you
agreed so far as the science is
concerned and then you were moving on to
the series of committees and bodies yeah
all right well can we start please with
the jcvi I think they are at the
there we are on the left hand side
um now highlighted in blue and The Joint
Committee for vaccines and immunization
um who do we expect to see on on that
committee and what is their role so the
first thing to say is that the
government Chief Scientific Advisor does
not attend the jcvi or indeed the other
specific methods uh within the
Department of Health
um and so I perhaps know a little bit
more about them because I do have a
medical background and so I can help in
that respect but not Quay being
government Chief Scientific Advisor well
thank you for making that claim may we
use you some Mark nevertheless to
provide us with some information
um so the Joint Council of vaccines and
immunization is an expert committee that
provides advice uh to the department and
the government on it does what it says
on the tin in fact on vaccines and
immunizations so it provides advice on
when vaccines are appropriate
how they should be used and so it and it
works of course with the medicines and
Healthcare products regulatory agency as
well because vaccines have to be
regulated so it's a very specific
advisory committee which was obviously
relevant to Corel virus and this of
course was the first pandemic which has
been possible to from scratch or nearly
scratch develop a vaccine during the
time course of a pandemic which was a
remarkable feat actually thank you
may I ask you to to provide a
description and explanation of the
advisory committee on dangerous
pathogens which if we go to the other
side of the chart we can see is now
highlighted in blue
um well again the same qualifications
before that I these are not committees
I've sat on there are a series of
dangerous pathogens some of them have
been known for a very long while Anthrax
would be an example of those
which can cop up crop up sporadically
and again that is a committee that is
designed specifically to provide advice
on pathogens of that sort
some may be new but there's diseases
like Ebola and Lassa there are a series
of them which
um require expert care when cases crop
up in the UK from time to time and does
that committee work across a range of
government organizations such as the
health and safety executive and the the
Department of Health and Social care
um it's uh I I think I can't really
answer that question perhaps that's for
someone else may we go up to the top
left of the plan and look at nerve tag
the new and emerging respiratory virus
threats Advisory Group
what can you tell us about um so I think
that is is very important and very
relevant to this inquiry
um and uh that is a newer committee than
the others I think it was set up in 2014
and started its work in 2015.
um and that actually recognized the fact
that over the past 25 years or so
um a number of new and emerging
respiratory viruses have cropped up in
different parts of the world and so
there was SARS in 2003
um there was the influenza pandemic in
2009 there have been outbreaks of Avian
Influenza there was then MERS and so I
think an increasing recognition
that
um
viruses were continuously emerging
and I think it's a point maybe I should
make now which is that all pandemics
start as emerging infections
right that is their nature yes and they
are typically zoonotic that means that
they start in an animal species and then
jump across to humans and there the
reason they are dangerous is because the
human populations don't have
pre-existing immunity and so they can
Rampage through human populations very
quickly
um and uh SARS which of course
um we may come onto it later has
slightly different characteristics to uh
this has been renamed as SARS cov1 and
the covid-19 virus is sarsko V2 sarsko
V1 mainly transmitted later on in
infection when people at their most
infectious but it did nevertheless
managed to travel around the world and
caused a lot of the harm in people such
as healthcare workers who are looking at
people at their sickest
um so there was a lot of concern about
these and in fact
um in the forward to the 2015 annual
report it was acknowledged that there
was the potential these these viruses
all did have Pandemic potential thank
you what is the difference between
the work of the advisory committee on
dangerous pathogens and nervative
um one is dealing with viruses that are
fairly well known the nerve tag is
specifically looking at new and emerging
infections
below the main blue box in the middle of
the page we can see a small yellow box
and within it are these words the
scientific pandemic influenza group on
modeling and just before I ask you about
that can we go above the main blue box
and just highlight
Sage together with the two smaller
yellow boxes that are underneath spib
and spimo could you explain to us please
sir Mark how those bodies and committees
work together
well these are in each case specialized
subcommitters that provide advices
scientific advice on different aspects
of infections as they develop
and modeling in particular
is a very important area why is it so
important well because
I mean the challenge is to know how an
infection is going to progress
um and
you can simply look at the doubling time
of an infection and sort of draw a
straight line the modelers can apply
rather more sophisticated measures to
that but I think the important thing
that it really is an important point is
that the what the modeling does is it
provides projections it doesn't provide
predictions and I think the other really
important thing is that
the uncertainty is at the greatest early
in any event when the numbers are
relatively small and so the early
projections can be quite wide
and so if you like they're starting to
give you uh scenarios on which people
can start planning what actions to take
um and uh so that's what that is about
and then uh there's also the sort of
Behavioral aspects and
um so a Behavioral Science is important
it's important in any emergency
and that's what it's by B in particular
is about
right so what is the connection between
I'm looking below the main blue box now
the scientific pandemic influenza group
on modeling and spy m o which is sitting
just below Sage I'm afraid I don't think
I can give you a certain answer on that
here and now I think I could come back
to you on that all right thank you very
much
um
we can we can take that down now thank
you I want to go on now please sir Mark
to ask you about
your opinion on the way in which these
scientific advisory groups are
commissioned
um the the inquiry has received witness
statements from many people involved in
them uh expressing a variety of opinion
about the the level of of freedom of
thought that that these committees have
outside of the precise tram lines of of
commissioning
um requests that that might come from
for instance the Department of Health
what is your view about the level of
freedom of thought that these groups
have outside of the the standard of
questioning um well so the first thing
to say is that because I was not a
member or party to those groups directly
I can't comment directly on how they
were asked to operate however I can make
some general comments
from my perspective as gcsa on how I
think they ought to operate if I may and
I think it turns on quite an important
challenge for
um providing science advice which is
that
um science advice is only effective if
it has a customer
and so ensuring that government
departments are as far as possible good
customers for research is an important
part of the work because they're not
instinctively necessarily looking for
scientific advice
um it in in the things that we did in go
science which included things like
Horizon scanning a very important part
of our work was to take if you like a
bottom-up view which is to ask the
experts that we were working with to
brainstorm and work out what could be
the issues and so I would see a
committee such as nerve tag as not only
answering specific questions that the
department might have had about
influenza but also providing spontaneous
input into the government department so
I think that there shouldn't be a
tension between being asked for advice
on specific matters and offering
spontaneous advice on things that the
committee feels is relevant otherwise
they don't believe that a government
department is getting the most out of
its expert committee so just to
summarize that and please tell me if if
I don't summarize it accurately I I
think what you're describing is a a a a
joined up
um cooperation between the the
requesting government department and the
scientific committee so perhaps the the
government Department going in with an
initial question but then
benefiting from the advice that the
committee can give it in in developing
those questions yes I I think precisely
so and one of the um initiatives that we
undertook was the government Jesus
Scientific Advisor was to
ask government departments about what
the research questions they were
interested in were so statements of
research interest was started to be
developed uh reflecting the fact that
science works best if it's a two-way
street in other words if you've got an
inquiring department and I mean going
back to a committee with the name nerve
tag new and emerging respiratory so it
ought to be that you're using that
committee to say there is this virus
here let's say MERS this is why my might
or might not be relevant to do some work
and I would cite as a you know something
that did happen was that
um at around 2015 the UK vaccines
network was set up which uh so Chris
Whitey who you'll be talking to soon
um chaired yes and they
did uh use what was then Oda funding to
start via a preparation for vaccines for
a number of viruses including the Mars
coronavirus and it was because of that
work that in 2020 Sarah Gilbert and her
team in Oxford were able to take the
work that in fact the British government
had funded through Oda
thinking that it would be used most
likely a vaccine in the developing World
repurposed that and that was the basis
of the Oxford AstraZeneca vaccine Oda
being the overseas development
assistance funding so so it wasn't that
there was not a it wasn't a scientific
recognition that these were and are very
important organisms and MERS still is a
dangerous virus
um and so there was there was vaccine
preparedness
just before we leave this topic um
you've described in terms of the working
relationship between the government
department and the scientific committee
as being a two-way street and that's the
ideal do you happen to know as a fact
whether or not in the run-up to the
pandemic that was the relationship that
existed with nerve tag I do not know as
a fact I've read the witness statements
and
yes well um the the inquiry will be able
to take note of the the contents of
those statements
one of the other
features of the witness statements to
which we refer from those who
sat on one and sometimes multiple
committees is the danger of group think
creeping in to a committee that might be
in the process of advising the
government what's your view of that and
how can that be avoided
um
I think that I mean to some extent that
depends on it depends on the uh the
chairing and the chemistry of the
meeting frankly
um my experience of chairing groups of
scientists is that um a group think is
not something that they are particularly
fond of it is the nature of science to
be asking questions to be skeptical and
the recruitment to these committers and
I you know I I obviously know many of
the individuals involved are these are
very independent-minded researchers from
a variety of different backgrounds and
so um I think that they are more
resistant to group thing than many
organizations but you know it'd be naive
for me to say that there isn't a
sometimes a danger group thing
um but I mean the best protection
against group think is is to have a
culture
where people can say what they think the
challenge is welcomed and that your
customer the government Department
whichever it is uh welcomes challenge
um that isn't always the case
could we put on screen please inq0101646
this is the code of practice for
scientific advisory committees and
councils which was updated most recently
in December 2021 just like to to read
this please given the interconnected and
complex nature of many of the topics on
which sacs that scientific advisory
committees advise they should operate as
an interactive component of the wider
science system within which they are
based a successful Sac will be one that
collaborates widely to deliver advice
that takes account of The Wider science
system and is integrated and coordinated
with other parts of it this requires
sacs to build appropriate connections
with the other components of the science
system within their sponsoring
organizations and to develop and or
maintain relationships with stakeholders
beyond their immediate Network
this confirms the value of joined up
thinking doesn't it across the whole
scientific spec
um and and I think is a very good
description of the way in fact they most
sacs do operate
um and so as part of the outside world
there are the National academies such as
the Royal Society the Royal Academy of
engineering the academic medical
Sciences
um and indeed uh during
um uh located pandemic uh Patrick
Valance asked the Academy of Medical
Sciences to produce a report on the
winter for example
um and so the the network of science
advice and again I'm always using that
in the broadest sense uh includes
Academia it includes the academies it is
quite International in its focus and
scientists can be brought in from abroad
um and
um it is a very dynamic
Affair so it is a
sage in particular is not a static
committee at all it brings in expertise
as needed and so I think this is a good
description and I think it is the way
that we try to make it work so the word
a successful Sac I think those are the
the characteristics of a successful
Scientific Advisor committee
do you think there is Merit in the
suggestion that some of these committees
should have a common Secretariat
um well I think it entirely depends on
their scope and the appropriateness of
that
um they are within the Department of
Health and Social care it does make
sense that there is coordination between
them and I can't comment on that but I I
think there is I'm not sure there is a
single answer but when they're dealing
with similar topics then Cross
membership is the other way of doing it
you don't necessarily need a common
Secretariat but Cross membership can
help and that's where officials
attending can be very helpful I think
and what about the suggestion that
perhaps there should be an annual
general meeting of all of these
committees or with some sort of event to
to bring them all together well again I
think different departments will handle
this in different ways and there are a
series of departments that have many of
these bodies defra is a department that
has many
um advisory groups as well and uh yes it
makes sense but I don't think one size
fits all
going to move on now please
please gusts with you sir Mark the role
of the government Chief Scientific
Advisor in relation to the National risk
assessments
uh you tell us at paragraph 15 in your
report that during your time as the gcsa
the CCS had overall responsibility for
the development of the NRA and for
working with individual departments and
across government as appropriate to
formulate and conduct civil
contingencies exercises and to provide
support in logistics for Cobra which
you've already made mention of and you
were involved in the development of I
think two nras during your time in
office is that right I think mainly with
the 2016 run actually yes all right well
we'll come to the 2016 nrn and I'm going
to ask you to explain certain aspects of
it in a moment but before we do that I'd
like to put on screen please a letter
which you sent to David Cameron in
October 2013. it's at inq000142113
we're going to look at three pieces of
Correspondence this one first and then
two later emails just to set the scene
of your involvement in this area
thank you now we can see
the date of this letter is the 16th of
October of 2013 and it's from you to the
Prime Minister and we'll read through it
together please you say I welcome the
2013 National risk assessment and agree
that the very high priority areas look
correct as such I'm happy to recommend
its approval I commend the additional
work on departmental risks that has been
undertaken by departmental Chief
scientific advisors and the natural
hazards partnership to ensure that the
best possible scientific evidence is
used
however I feel there are a number of
actions which could further strengthen
the NRA
as was discussed in cabinet yesterday
morning I agree with Francis Maude that
thorough review of the NRA for next year
is necessary the key issue is to ensure
that the NRA is used and does not become
a heavy document that is filed in secret
filing cabinets in particular a good
risk register should drive thinking
about how risks can be prevented
mitigated handled if they transpire and
to clear up afterwards the NRA is used
fairly effectively for the handling and
clear-up but variably to drive decisions
about prevention and mitigation let's
just pause that so what what were your
concerns about the limited way in which
the NRI was being utilized yes so I mean
the first thing to say is of course 2013
was the year I started as gcsa so I came
into the process after it had been going
for some time
but one thing I did discover was that
the NRA was held at a quite highly
certified level which meant that very
few people saw it it was actually locked
in departmental statements at the time
and I felt that that wasn't the most
effective way to hold a a risk
assessment
um and secondly and I think this is a
quite an important broader issue
um
the individual risks are held by
individual government departments the
CCS has to cover the whole of government
with a relatively small staff
and so most of the ccs's work was used
in
managing events when they happened in
other words providing the emergency
advice the emergency Operational Support
and then to some extent helping with the
clear-up depending on what it is whereas
the whole point of a risk assessment is
that you ought to be able to use it to
see if you can stop something happening
in the first place if it is going to
happen to mitigate it in other words
reduce its effects and then also handle
and clear up
and I was concerned that I didn't think
there was sufficient work on
um the prevention and mitigation
and I would have had doubts then and now
that ccs would be the body to do that
and I think it turns on broader
questions of resilience that we may come
back to yes well whilst we're on this
this topic
um did
the use of the NRA in areas of
prevention and mitigation improve during
your time in office in your opinion um I
think it was a work in progress and I
think it's still a work in progress
um because it raises I think there are
some very fundamental questions about
who pays which again we may come on to
um I could expand on that now or later
um
so it might be appropriate for you to do
that now okay
um so so
it comes to the challenge that
um firstly most risks cover a number of
government departments it's very rare
for them to be confined to one
government Department
um and
one of the clear issues in relation to
the coronavirus pandemic is the strength
of Public Health
um and I would argue and again this is
really from my Professional Knowledge
rather than Quay government Chief
Scientific Advisor
that
the challenge for public health is
always that the Urgent is the enemy of
the important
so a department that is faced with
waiting lists for a hospital for example
inevitably is going to be under pressure
to solve that rather than taking on the
long-term public health issues which
actually will prevent people getting
into trouble later in life and so the
question I think always is who pays for
the insurance policy in the case of
flooding uh
it's fine to manage the flood when it
happens but who is actually going to pay
for the flood prevention and if you look
across the whole of government there are
so many areas of national resilience
um that It ultimately is a political
decision to decide how much to invest in
preparation for events that are going to
happen in the future climate change is
another example of that or prevention of
known risks yes
um and so I think that by devolving the
budgets to individual government
departments they are always Under
Pressure to deal with the immediate
rather than if you might be coming down
and so I think a really important
question when we think about National
resilience is that it does need to be
looked at as a whole cross-government
issue
and I I think all over that twin
yesterday was talking about having a
senior Minister responsible for it that
obviously is a matter for government is
that something that you would support it
is something I would support and in fact
I had the pleasure of working reasonably
closely with Oliver letter and when he
was the translator of Lancaster
um
and
the the other issue is the the issue of
cascading risks which is that when one
thing goes wrong other things go wrong
as well so again to give an example
which is not from Health when there were
the floods
um in around 2013 in the southwest uh
they Tran the weakness of the transport
links to uh Devon and Cornwall were
exposed when a part of the embankment
went to dawlish and so you one event can
Cascade into another and a pandemic that
was even more serious than the kobit 19
pandemic could well have caused work
absenteeism and collapse of national
infrastructure
um and a good example of that is that
imagine the pandemic if the internet had
broken down
if if transport lines had broken and we
would even get food and so as modern
societies have become more efficient
they have actually become less resilient
and are dependent on just-in-time supply
lines
um so you really do need to take a
cross-government view
and I think that one of the important
lessons of this pandemic is that we need
to take a much more serious look at
risks through the lens of resilience
um and again sort of to to extend that a
bit further Ukraine has taught us the
risks in terms of uh supply lines around
grains and and uh inert gases for
example which are important for the
lasers that make semiconductors so uh
one's got to look at resilience at a
cross-government level yes and I don't
think that that has been happening
sufficiently
and if I may one more comment at this
point which may or may not have come up
a bit later my sense when I arrived was
that the
the Civil contingent Secretariat and a
lot of the work around
um
the risk assessment uh came from the
world of of human threats as opposed to
National hazards and so many of the
staff of the ccs would have had security
type backgrounds and I think that was
much more of a focus and Catherine
Hammond in her evidence I think made
this point herself probably more focused
on threats malicious threats than on
natural hazards and I think that's quite
an important issue yes thank you
and let's return for a moment to the
letter please and look at the second
bullet point on the page where you say
to the Prime Minister I think that the
NRA could also be used more effectively
to prepare for the handling of
emergencies as they arise indeed I have
been working closely with the cabinet
office to ensure scientific scrutiny of
key risks as part of this work I have
requested that scientific briefing
papers are created for each of the very
high priority risks considerable work
has already been done in creating these
for both t44 and h23 is h23 at the
pandemic yes T stands for threats and H
for hazard so yeah one of each
although a number of duplicate risks
have been removed from this year's NRA I
believe more could be done to reduce the
overall number of risks whilst I'm
content for risks to be moved across
from the NRA to the nsra continued
scientific review of these should be
conducted
what was your concern there sir mark
um
I think it's a sort of my concern was
over signal to noise ratio if I can put
it that way which is that there were
enormous number of lists the the NRA and
the nsra have now been merged yes
um the nsra was looking to take a a a
global and international
uh view of the security risks in
particular uh with the NRA was more
local
um so there was some level of
duplication there
um but I think that there is a corollary
of this which is that
um
the risks come across as being very
granular and that's an issue that you've
already spoken to a number of witnesses
about which is
um
in the case of Hazards there are many
scenarios and so looking through at
risks through the lens of scenarios is
an important way of doing it in other
words rather than saying the pandemic is
influenza there are a number of possible
pandemics and one needs to brainstorm
each of those
and that applies to almost every risk
and Hazard actually which is that uh
earthquakes come in many forms volcanoes
might come in many forms from ones that
emit clouds of Ash to ones that emits
vast amounts of sulfur dioxide and so
almost any risk you look at needs to be
looked at through a whole variety of
scenarios multiples multiple scenarios
yes
um recognizing and this is probably more
so with the case of pandemics than
anything else that it is almost
impossible
to predict what the next pandemic will
be
with the one qualification that we know
that the influenza is the pandemic that
keeps coming back all right well we're
going to turn very shortly to look at
the national risk assessments and how
those worked in practice but before we
do and before we leave this letter I'd
just like to to highlight the final
paragraph because it touches upon
something that you've already begin to
to tell us about this morning sir mark
it would be helpful for future
iterations to have a Behavioral Science
Viewpoint for example how people react
in the event of an evacuation or how
First Responders react in an emergency
situation now just to remind ourselves
this letter was written by you in
October of 2013. as you have explained
as you were coming into post
um is this
aspect of Behavioral Science as uh as as
a as an important consideration in terms
of risk assessment something which you
saw developing during your time in
office is it something that has yet
really to be taken seriously
um I think it's taken seriously and I
think it was taken seriously then
um but it is uh very protein in its
nature and I I think that in the areas
that I was involved then there's no
doubt that Behavioral Science did
continue to develop and did make a
difference and the example which is
cited quite often was the Ebola pandemic
sorry epidemics
Ebola epidemic
um where Behavioral Science was
extremely important in understanding the
mode of transmission at funerals in West
Africa and we had a specific an expert
anthropologist
advising us on
Sage
who actually helped operation in the end
because it turned out that burial in
West Africa uh respect is shown to the
corpse by touching and sadly in Ebola
which is transmitted by touch people are
most infectious as they're dying and
just after they've died and in fact the
height of the status of the corpse the
more people touch them
um and of course the simple answer was
to say well you must have stopped
touching them but this was a culturally
deeply sensitive issue and so
anthropology was very helpful it's a
rather detailed example but it just
shows how important it is
um and there are you know many examples
where it's important to understand
behaviors for example
um telling people not to Panic by the
rational responses to go and panic bye
so understanding Behavioral Science is
quite important
and here you were inviting a Viewpoint
of Behavioral Science to be included in
the NRA assessments did did that in fact
happen
um well the NRH assessments were still
it was quite a thick document
um probably not to the extent that uh
ultimately we need all right thank you
can we take that down please and replace
it with an email which you sent to
Julian Miller in the cabinet office in
June of 2014 it's at
inq000142145 thank you
and um if we could
scroll down please to the paragraph
which begins I remain of the opinion and
read through that here you are saying to
Mr Miller I remaining of the opinion
however that response and Recovery is
any part of the benefit of a successful
risk management it is surely an
important to be proactive it is
important as important to be proactive
in taking steps to prevent events from
happening in the first place or if that
isn't possible to take steps to mitigate
against their effects as such I'm Keen
for us to explore how government could
use the nsra and indeed the NRA they
were separate at the time most
effectively to avoid and mitigate
against specific risks
cpni what is that a reference to
um I oh gosh what's that acronym for
Center for protection National
infrastructure I think thank you if I'm
wrong we'll correct it after right
I'm glad that you you struggle as much
as we do but that's not quite as much
and CPI do this for the range of threats
to the UK's infrastructure by developing
a detailed understanding of the impacts
of such events which leads to
evidence-based approaches to tackling
them they then work with the owners and
operators of the UK's National
infrastructure to provide appropriate
tailored advice I would like to see how
this approach might be widened to cover
natural hazards as well so here you were
Sir Mark following year in June of 2014
again expressing your view that there
needed to be a more proactivity around
taking steps to prevent events from
happening and that that wasn't in your
view being given sufficient attention
yes I mean I think that takes me back to
the point I made about public health
which is that
um in the in the case of the approach to
a pandemic and again this is me speaking
really with my
medical background as it were there and
scientific background there are two
things you can do you can firstly
try and identify the hazards in earlier
the earliest opportunity in other words
have Global screening for emerging
infections uh proper transparency and
data sharing uh you can be proactive in
developing vaccines that might be
relevant but the other thing you can do
is reduce the vulnerability of the
population right because a risk is
basically a combination of the hazard
itself the exposure to the hazard of the
vulnerability of people to the hazard so
risk is the sort of multiple of those
three things so if the state of health
is poor so if the state of health is
poor you're going to do less well that
may well be why the vulnerability to the
influence pandemic at the end of the
first world war with the H1N1 for the
virus kills millions of people whereas a
very similar virus in 2009 of course
fortunately rather have smaller numbers
of deaths thank you thank you
thank you we can take that down please
and replace it with the final piece of
Correspondence which was a letter from
you to Felicity Oswald Nichols in the
CCs in October of 2014 so
three months later
and can we please
scroll down
thank you
at the middle paragraph beginning
secondly middle bullet point you see you
say here secondly I think there are four
reasons to have a risk assessment to
prevent the risk to mitigate the risk to
respond to it and to recover
the response and Recovery have been
addressed in your work to date however I
think we need to actively look at what
the government can do to avoid and
mitigate against risks this remains an
outstanding issue and I would like to
see this tackled more effectively in the
coming months so here you are raising
the issue again several months later
with the Civil contingencies Secretariat
yes I'm beginning to sound like a broken
record aren't I um
um yes I I I I mean I think that
UK has a strong risk register so I think
we have to start from the premise that
actually it's not every government does
have but I think it is really important
to use it as well as possible and I
think it is a work in progress so I
think it it would be unreasonable to
expect all these problems to have been
solved in a very short period but I
think it's important to people keep
people in mind of this and it is again
the challenge of the Urgent over the
important thank you
we can take that down please and let's
then go to the National risk assessment
of 2016 which was uh which which had
your involvement let's put up please inq
zero double zero one four double seven
six nine thank you very much you're
ahead of me
um this is the first page we can just
confirm that this is the right National
risk assessment can we go to page 47
please
now as that's being done Sir Mark just
to confirm what the inquiry has already
heard that the national risk assessment
is a medium-term planning tool for civil
emergency plans affecting the UK over
the next uh over the next five years or
so and it should be handled consistently
it should be evidence-based and it's and
it's dealt with on the basis of a
reasonable worst case scenario which is
an illustration of examples of of the
worst plausible manifestation of of
whatever the risk or Hazard that's been
considered is that right yes okay
so this is the page dealing with
pandemic influenza we can see that in
the top left hand corner and we can see
that the graph at the top right hand
corner which the inquiry has already
seen I think so Chris De for wormald was
taken through this by Mr Keith a couple
of days ago
um has two axes impact running
vertically and likelihood and
plausibility running horizontally now in
terms of pandemic influenza we can see
that in 2016
the assessment was that it posed a very
high risk and we know that because we
can see the words very high in the top
left box and we can see that the star
indicating its position on this graph is
at the top
aligned with catastrophic impact and
medium to high likelihood or
plausibility with an arrow going in a
downwards Direction can you explain to
us please what that represents
um well I mean that actually is the
range in other words
um the the range of the assessment is
that there was a medium up to high
likelihood that there would be a a
pandemic of influenza in this case
um and that it could range between you
know significant to catastrophic right
can we scroll All Out please and move
further down the page and look at
the main box under outcome description
because we can see there that this
assessment is based on a worldwide
outbreak of influenza occurring when a
novel flu virus emerges with sustained
human to human transmission and it's on
the basis that up to 50 percent of the
population may experience symptoms which
could lead to up to 750 000 fatalities
in total in the UK absenteeism would be
significant and could reach 20 for two
to three weeks at the height of the
pandemic either because people are
personally ill or caring for someone who
is ill causing significant impact on
business continuity each pandemic is
different and the nature of the virus
and its impacts cannot be known in
detail in advance now just pausing there
that's something to which you've already
made reference the fact that nobody
really knows the precise details of the
pandemic that will hit but these are
these figures and these um assessments
are based upon a reasonable worst case
scenario is that right yes
um it's a
there is an unreasonable worst case
scenario as well in other words where
there could be several times more that
number of fatalities yes so there are I
mean one of the big issues here is the
sort of slight hubris that uh humans can
always beat nature
um and a gastric pandemic uh could kill
an awful lot of people this was a
working model but you know one shouldn't
place any Precision around the numbers
uh this is an unmitigated situation
though isn't it it doesn't take into
account no this one is this this one
this one this is a
this is not unmiticated I mean this this
is an example of a a very severe
influenza pandemic which would cause
which could cause 750 000 fatalities yes
you've mentioned um sir Oliver letwin's
evidence to the inquiry yesterday uh in
which he
warned against the danger of
um of of
concentrating too much perhaps on the
likelihood of of a scenario happening
and in his view what was important was
not to ignore those Black Swan events
where the likelihood might be very low
or or low-ish but the impact if an event
like that hits would be
catastrophic would be overwhelming what
do you say about that I I I I agree with
it actually
um and
I think that that sentence you read each
pandemic is different yes and the nature
of the virus and its impacts cannot be
known in detail in advance
um and I think that where this would
have been better described would be
rather than focusing solely on influenza
it ought to recognized the fact that
pandemics come in many different forms
and
um
add as I think probably as Chris
Whittier will tell you because he's
written on the the different infections
transmitted in different ways
and so the pandemic depends on the
nature of the transmission it depends on
the nature of the organism
there are infinite variables effectively
right
based on understanding of previous
pandemics a pandemic is likely to occur
in one or more waves possibly weeks and
months apart that each wave May last
between 12 to 15 weeks and
what do you say of the view that's been
expressed that that really this worst
reasonable worst case scenario was
somewhat out of date because it was
based mainly upon what happened in the
um flu outbreak
um no I don't think so
um uh it's the nature of flu that it is
constantly it has a particular capacity
to evolve because it it it flew you find
in three species and humans in pigs and
in birds and it has a particular genome
which is divided into pieces which means
it can Shuffle its genome relatively
straightforwardly
um and so I think that was a perfectly
plausible planning scenario but um you
are anything like that is
as it were making projections or not
really predictions for the future the
Retro spectroscope is a 100 accurate
instrument and so governments are always
best prepared for the last event but
this is a perfectly plausible
um scenario all right
reading on all ages may be affected but
we cannot know until the virus emerges
which groups will be most at risk
correct there is no known evidence of
association between the rate of
transmissibility and severity of
infection meaning it is possible that a
new influenza virus could be both highly
transmissible and cause serious cause
severe symptoms that that would be the
the the worst case scenario would it not
because and in the rare cases where
humans have caught Avian Influenza it
has been a highly lethal infection
fortunately it hasn't developed into a
pandemic but there are reasons to be
concerned
pandemics significantly more serious
than the rwcs reasonable worst case
scenario are therefore possible and the
impact of the countermeasures in any
given pandemic is difficult to predict
as it will depend on the nature of the
virus and the reasonable worst case
scenario assumes countermeasures are not
effective
so that's what I was referring to before
when I indicated that this was a
reasonable worst case scenario in an
unmitigated circumstances
um I I mean the the difference between
influenza and
um the SARS cov2 virus is that
um
there are established vaccines for
influenza though they they would not
work for a new pandemic strain but they
might provide some level of protection
um and antivirals have been developed
although there is always a risk of
mutation in the virus which will allow
it to escape an antiviral drug pretty
easily actually
um so I think that this was a perfectly
reasonable
worst case scenario but it was one of
about 500 worst case scenarios that
could be written all right before we
leave this page could we just scroll
down to the next paragraph please
confidence levels high confidence
we can see that at the top of the zoomed
page high confidence in the overall
assessment based on a large body of
knowledge of the issue and includes
evidence of a high quality informed by
consistent relevant expert judgments
what does that refer to please
well I think I I think if you like the
the
what we know about pandemic infections
um justifies a description of a scenario
such as that right pandemic influenza
infections or pandemic infections both
right
well let's take that down please and
just before we break can we go to Annex
a of the 2016 NRA as inq 0 double zero
one seven six seven seven zero
that
this relates to the same risk it's a
pandemic influenza but at this line as
it does in Annex a provides a greater
level of information about the way in
which at this risk has been assessed so
can we scroll down please
thank you and
look at the paragraph
specific assumptions at the bottom of
the page thank you here we see the
reasonable worst case scenario is based
upon the experience and mathematical
analysis of influenza pandemics in the
20th and 21st century the specific
assumptions of the scenario are and then
if we can scroll down to get those on
the page please we don't need to go
through them in detail but but can you
confirm please sir Mark that this is the
the calculation these are the the
matters that go into performing and
making the reasonable worst case
scenario
below the bullet points we see this
while combining these figures can be
misleading and there is unlikely to be
both high-end illness and death rates
resulting in around 750 000 deaths this
is the advised reasonable worst case for
guiding planning nationally and the
figure has been recommended by the
scientific pandemic influencers subgroup
on modeling spy m
are you able to help us with this please
sir Mark what is the process by which uh
spy M would calculate the figures and
then and then feed them through for this
reasonable worst case scenario to be
calculated how practically does that
happen
um
I think that I'm probably not the right
person to answer that question because I
know what's happened recently which is
that certainly during coronavirus the um
the sage and the government were not
reliant on a single modeling subgroup in
other words there are groups of modelers
in different universities who are acting
independently to reach their figure what
I cannot tell you for this whether this
was done as one modeling group or a lot
of modelers right so I'm afraid I I
think that's a question for others
um but um I mean the principles of
mathematics modeling is that you take
those parameters and you use them to
make a projection yes
thank you well we'll leave it there I
think and if we need to we can ask
another witness to expand on that my
lady is that a convenient time to break
excuse me thank you very much Miss black
girl I shall return it 25 past 11.
foreign
sorry about the slight delay in
restarting my lady
have on screen imq zero double zero one
four double seven six nine and go to
page 48 please
zoom in on the top part of the page this
is
the
equivalent page for emerging infectious
diseases and on the right hand side
using the same axes on the table we can
see that emerging infectious diseases
are placed
by a star at moderate impact and medium
to high likelihood or plausibility with
an arrow
showing an upper range and an Arrow
showing a lower range
in the column
of medium likelihood or plausibility
yes I mean what this reflects is a high
degree of uncertainty right all right
well so uh an emerging infectious
disease might turn out to be you know
effectively a damp squid but not much
happen or it could and Mer's actually a
very good example
cause a very significant event in Korea
for example and the fact that it got to
Career it could have got anywhere and
there was an outbreak there that caused
I think 38 deaths and there were 153
cases showing how dangerous
and infection it is so the answer is
that there are many infectious diseases
that emerge and ultimately they can turn
into pandemics as we saw with sarsko V2
could we zoom out please and look at the
confidence levels which are just below
the midpoint on the page
reflecting on what you've just said I
think Sir Mark yeah low confidence in
the overall assessment based on a
relatively small body of knowledge of
the issue and includes relevant evidence
and somewhat consistent relevant expert
judgments
are you able to
explain to us Sir Mark why the
confidence level in relation to pandemic
influenza was high but the confidence
level in relation to emerging infectious
diseases is low
um well so I'll deal with the the latter
first which is that there are so many
different emerging infections with
different transmission Pathways
different clinical effects different
severity that
um
the the small body of knowledge is not
because people are sort of foolish or
ignorant about it it's just simply these
things have not existed before and
therefore no one knows about them until
they come out and the amazing power of
modern science means that we are able to
characterize the Genome of the SARS cov2
virus in a matter of weeks whereas it
took 15 years in the 1918 pandemic to
discover what the agent that caused
influenza was the virus
um it was mistakenly thought to be
caused by bacterium
bacterium at the time
excuse me and if you like I think the
um
the higher confidence in the influenza
is that it was looking at a pandemic
where you could be confident that if it
turns into a pandemic it would have a
catastrophic impact and so one of these
emerging effects is when it turns into a
pandemic because it flips the page back
to the previous one the the pandemic
risk so the level of of variability if
you like leads to the confidence being
lower the answer yes exactly the
uncertainty is much higher all right
thank you we can take that down now and
please could we replace it with the
Royal Academy of engineering review
and the scenarios it
paragraph 2.1 which we can see at
inq00068403
just to put this in context this was a
review
um which we can see into the external it
was an external review sorry of the
National Security risk assessment
methodology
um conducted recently and if we can go
to page
16.
and have a look at paragraph 2.1
under scenario design could we highlight
that paragraph please
so the Royal Academy of engineering
looked into the methodology of the nsra
system and amongst other matters raised
the following questions what are
alternative approaches to the reasonable
worst case scenario what would be their
added value in comparison to the
reasonable worst case scenario how are
reasonable worst case scenarios or other
types of scenarios Divine defined how
can consistency be insured across a wide
variety of different risks both
malicious and nomalicious chronic and
acute domestic and international and
then this should the nsra focus on a
single reasonable worst case scenario or
should it plan for more generic or
multiple scenarios per risk for example
pandemic pandemic influenza versus
multiple pandemic scenarios and should
different risks be grouped together and
only the reasonable worst case scenarios
be
for examples pandemic and animal disease
what is your view Sir Mark on whether or
not
there should be a more generic or
multiple scenario
approach to to risk planning well I
tackled this to some extent in my
witness statement actually which is that
I think that a scenario-based approach
is a much better approach why um because
I think it well because because it
enables you to Encompass more
variability where there is variability
so as we're a single person with a gun
is fairly easy to Define but a a a a a
the huge variability of the natural
world and the hazards that we Face means
that you can only I think best think
about it through a range of scenarios
and if I may I think it also turns on
exercising as well which is that
the opportunity and real costs of one of
the major national
um uh exercises is absolutely huge which
means that you can't do them very often
and so you end up putting an enormous
amount of effort into one particular
scenario whereas if if you actually
at a smaller scale do lots of expert
assessments tabletop exercises exploring
a range of scenarios
then I think that's a much more
practical approach to the complexity
that the natural world throws us
this suggestion with which you agree is
set out in this report which has been
commissioned in recent times are you
able to help the inquiry with with why
this
issue had not been considered and
grappled with back in 2016 or 2017 or
2019.
I think that
organizations go through continuous
Improvement and I think this is part of
the same thing I don't think anything
should say still should it have happened
some time ago
yes probably but the answer is that it's
better late than never and I think that
one learns lessons continuously which is
why this inquiry is so important for me
at paragraph 78 in your report you say
this a key question in relation to
pandemic preparedness is whether the
United Kingdom was too distracted by the
risk of an influenza pandemic to
properly prepare for a pandemic caused
by another microorganism I do not think
that this was the case during my time at
the gcsa
um so I think that
I want to distinguish two things I think
scientifically
the country was quite prepared then in
the sense that it was recognized I think
operational preparedness is another
matter and I think it's clear that we
were not operationally prepared and I
say that later in my witness statement
actually
could could we go under
by not being operationally prepared
um well it goes back to the discussion
that we had earlier about public health
yes
um and I think that
um
a focus in richer countries uh moved
away from infectious diseases after the
second world war good public health and
with the rise of chronic inflammatory
diseases cardiac disease hypertension
diabetes there was much more of a focus
on those and away from infection
but I think also
um and I referred in my witness
statement to a paper written by Dr
classical yes who wrote a very
interesting history comparing Public
Health in the USA the UK and Germany
going right back to 1900. I think you
know as well don't you see here's an
expert now yeah he has been appointed
but I think that's a was a powerful
analysis and I think if you look at the
history of Public Health there has been
a long-standing decline in our capacity
to fight infectious disease going back
40 or 50 years or more how has that
happened
um well those are ultimately uh
political decisions about the allocation
of resources right
um and it goes back to the fact that
um
the National Health Service is to a
significant extent the national disease
service it is pressure you know it is
treating people who are ill now
and so there has been a move away from
Public Health
and I think if you go back to the 19th
century every part of the country had a
medical officer of health and every year
they would write an annual report on the
health of their local communities very
largely focused on infection in those
days
and part of the control of the infection
is to have an effective distributed
system
for
testing tracing and we're appropriately
isolating people with infectious
diseases and we had lost that capability
over a very prolonged period And as just
one concrete example but there are many
the public health laboratory system
which was a distributed system and I I
should say again I'm saying this really
from my Professional Knowledge and I
should also say that I am not actually a
Public Health Physician by training I'm
a immunologist rheumatologist but
nevertheless that distributed capacity
for testing for disease had largely been
lost and the closure of the public
health Laboratories in about 2004 was
just one step on the way
well I'd like to to take up that point
please because in paragraph 129 of your
report you provide some facts and
figures you say that
um 13 of the 69 public health health
Laboratories were closed over a period
of time and a central laboratory of
communicable disease surveillance was
created at colindale which led in your
View to a decline in this decline in the
perceived importance of the locally
based surveillance Laboratories is that
right it is uh but I I as I say in my
witness statement this section of the
report was heavily dependent on Dr
Coachella so you have him as your
advisor
what about the fact
Public Health laboratory service was
merged with the NHS local microbiology
Services what what effect did that have
well I think again it it it it took them
away from a sort of broader surveillance
into dealing with the everyday needs of
the
District hospitals which you know these
aren't either or things we need both
all right thank you
um
I'd like to ask you some questions now
about the
biosecurity strategy how that came into
being and how that assists in this area
of risk assessment and planning
um
yes
um so
um
one of the groups that I chaired when I
was at the government's Scientific
Advisor was a rather obscure committee
with the name of
nscos and T which stands for National
Security Council officers science and
technology and
to some extent it reflects my concern
that I raised earlier that an awful lot
of the focus of the work on National
resilience was on malicious threats
rather than natural hazards but one
thing that was apparent was that
biological threats come from different
sources and with the responsibilities of
different parts of government
so there are animal diseases which were
very much the responsibility of defra
there were
the threats from natural infections of
humans which were very responsibility of
a Department of Health and Social care
and its Associated bodies and then there
was malicious biological threats as well
where the home office had quite an
important role
and increasingly in the world of Health
people are taking a one Health view
which is actually to say that
different species we are intimately
interrelated to each other so each human
as an example carries one kilogram of
bacteria as our microbiome mainly in our
gut and so we we are
sorry about that
um
so and and plants and animals and so
looking at particularly infectious
diseases without looking across the
whole of biology and different species
doesn't make much sense and so we needed
an integrated strategy and that was
started as a result of the work of um
it came from NSC OS and T the work was
led initially by the home office and it
started in 2015 in 2018 the biological
security strategy was published for the
first time and it is literally just in
the last month or two been updated so
that is the origin of that and it was an
example of trying to take an integrated
approach to Natural hazards but also
threats in the case of um because
biological agents can be used for
malicious purposes as well and it's
about integrating them thank you is the
strategy overseen by the government
Chief Scientific Advisor
um I can't tell you the answer to that
no I'm afraid um it was initiated that
way but the strategy was not owned by I
mean again it comes back to the fact
that its government departments that had
to own it so this was owned jointly
across government yes all right thank
you
the next topic please the sage science
guidance paper I just want to touch upon
this please and could we please put up
inq 0 double zero
um one four two one three nine
and turn to page eight
thank you
can you explain to us please to Mark
what the sage science guidance paper is
so this was commissioned
um as a the challenge for sage is do you
start from a blank Siege paper which is
what was pretty much happening when I
started and
it seemed to make sense to me that we
should actually try and get some
guidelines for sage so that we could
kick off with a not a detailed plan but
with an idea of the questions that might
be important and these were commissioned
and this was
um
one of those so a guidance document here
for the members of sage when they are
going about when there's nothing
assessment yes okay and if we look at
the bottom part of the page and the
table can you explain to us what we have
on the left hand side in conjunction
with the right hand side please uh so
the left hand side is that there is an
emerging disease of some kind and the
government is requesting scientific
advice on it so it sets up with key
questions
um what we know about the disease in the
microbe that causes it do we know
whether it kills people what's the
nature of the illness do we know what
the microbe is do we know how it's
transmitted I could read through it all
yes and then on the right hand side
um key questions for sage are how can we
answer these questions what do we need
to know in order to generate the answers
and in order to get the best out of sage
you would envisage as you've described
before that ideally there would be an
interconnection there would be a
conversation a two-way street absolutely
you've described it between Cobra on one
side and Sage on the other
yes well I mean the job of sage is to is
the object the the job of sage is to
advise the government Chief Scientific
Advisor uh plus or minus a relevant CSA
in this case the CMO uh or the CSA in in
in health and they they go from Sage to
provide the advice at Cobra
um and so the right hand side is that
these are the questions for the
scientific group
and how
are the members of sage expected to
utilize this guidance
um well these are the questions that the
the the the first meeting on Sage would
be these are the questions we had been
asked these are the things that we need
to know can you help you know what is
your advice as experts in the area
um and they they get fed data as it
comes in as well because
um the again it's one of the strengths
of the system actually that
um the department of sort of the NHS
and dhsc
um have protocols for example for the
first hundred patients with a new
disease and so there are ways of
discovering quickly the answer to these
questions some of them are harder than
others
thank you we can take that down now
[Applause]
I want to
finally ask you please sir Mark about
your views on the need for a national
resilience assessment to act as a basis
for resilience planning
um
at paragraph 117 in your report to us
you say regardless of which approach
government takes in the future to
funding and providing National
resilience I think that there is a good
case for government to create a national
resilience assessment to act as a basis
for resilience planning what do you mean
by that idea well I suppose stepping
back
um it seems to me that the prime duties
of government are to look after the
health the well-being the resilience and
security of all of us the citizens and
of course the component of that is the
strength of the economy because if you
don't have a decent economy you can't
have any of that but the resilience is a
really important lens to look at the
health well-being and security of
us and as we've discussed several times
uh during
um my parents
um
resilience is something that you have to
look at very broadly and so I think that
I I at the end of the day
it's people that matter here it's it's
sort of uh you can set up all kinds of
structures but I think it's a question
for
government and it's a question I think
for this inquiry
um to decide you know if if it's agreed
that resilience is an important way of
looking at it then it needs to be
prioritized within government
um and a government needs to think about
um what are the
form should follow functions so decide
what the function of the sort is and
then work out a form that's going to
work Oliver lettings suggested that
there should be a minister and that
would make complete sense
um and uh looking and then it's not it's
not this isn't a as it were a
replacement for the risk register it's a
way of looking at the risks through that
lens of resilience how the
interdependence of different government
departments in all of this the fact it
doesn't sit neatly into one government
Department
um and
I think it applies to all areas of
um Modern Life where as I say as I think
the danger for us is that as we have
become more efficient we have become
less resilient and you can have
cascading failures very very quickly so
for example when a super tanker got
stuck in the Suez Canal then suddenly
supply lines were disrupted and if that
had happened for any period it would
have caused major supply issues for all
sorts of things it comes on things like
the dependence on semiconductors so it's
it's pretty all-consuming but it clearly
has a relevance for
um
19. and and if I may I just like to
extend it to the whole question about
um the inequalities in health which have
been already raised
um and
the challenge the the the so there's no
question that and you've had the
evidence from Michael Marmot and his
colleagues as well that the
vulnerability of citizens of the UK and
around the world has very much depended
on their social circumstances on
um how deprived they are on black and
Asian ethnic minority minority ethnic
groups being more susceptible and more
vulnerable
now the only thing you can do there when
the pandemic arises is try and reduce
transmission uh resilience is about
actually providing the public health
coverage to reduce that vulnerability
and it is I think about getting Public
Health out into the community so a
Workforce that could help in the
screening for hypertension diabetes
heart disease would then be a Workforce
that could be repurposed for the
purposes of vaccination
and all of the things that are testing
and things like that so I think it is
about how we look and see how we can
make the population the most resilient
which will protect us against the
effects of future pandemics to some
extent
despite everything we do there is always
the possibility of some devastating
disease emerging which we find we can do
not much about it but the better the
better it is about be prepared being
prepared and being resilient for for
what might be coming down the line okay
finally then could I ask please for your
comments on this document it's the
witness statement of John Swinney
inq000185-352 and paragraph 26.
thank you
here he says one of the Hallmarks of the
operating approach of the Scottish
government during the period of scrutiny
in this module was to engage widely with
other public authorities
public bodies business and third sector
organizations to create a sense of
common purpose in our endeavors this
approach would involve the establishment
of a range of collaborative forums in
which the aspirations of ministers could
be set out and practical work
commissioned to try to realize these
aspirations there was also an analytical
structure put in place to assess
progress in achieving these aspirations
through a broadly endorsed National
performance framework the national
performance framework established an
agreed set of outcomes that
organizations in Scotland were working
together to achieve these included are
collective aspirations for children and
young people the economy communities the
tackling of inequalities human rights
Fair work and business and the tackling
of poverty the fact that the national
performance framework was valued and
supported by a broad range of public
private sector organizations in Scotland
helped to focus our pandemic response
and assisted our efforts to be effective
for example in addressing inequalities
this approach created a strong platform
for the necessary and Urgent dialogue
that was required in preparing for and
then ultimately managing the pandemic
I don't want to
seek your views on the political aspect
of what's set out there but broadly
speaking do you approve of and support
the the procedure that's that's being
described there in terms of the the
collection of considerations of
government and also of private sector
organizations
um
well I I think it's quite difficult to
avoid the politics here because this is
essentially a political statement in
other words it is a statement that they
have decided to operate through a
widespread stakeholder consultation
um and uh that seems a perfectly
reasonable approach but I don't I don't
think it is in fact
science or science advice per se so I
think it is a political statement to be
honest all right well then I I won't ask
anything further we'll leave it there
will you excuse my back please
I'm told that um there are no rule 10
questions
and so and that is the right expression
well
no we have had rule 10 questions but we
haven't provided permission or you my
lady you haven't provided permission for
them so that in fact concludes the
evidence of thank you very much thank
you very much I'd like to be extremely
helpful
um and
um very interesting so thank you for
your help thank you milady
thank you
yes thank you very much I think my lady
were going straight into the next
Witness
my lady the next witness is the Deputy
Prime Minister
foreign
I swear by almighty God
the evidences I shall give
shall be the truth
the whole truth
and nothing but the truth
Deputy Prime Minister could you please
provide your name yes Oliver James
Dowden
thank you very much for your assistance
in this inquiry and for attending today
whilst I ask you questions could you
please remember to keep your voice up so
that we may have the benefit of hearing
what you have to say and also for the
purposes of the stenographer's record if
I ask you a question which is not clear
feel free to ask me to repeat it
you have provided a witness statement
dated and signed the 18th of April 2023
could we have please on the screen one
eight three three three two thank you
very much and page five
the
statement of Truth
to which you have appended your
signature is that correct yes that's
that's correct and may I begin Mr Keith
just by reiterating what I said at the
beginning of that statement which is to
say that the
the covert crisis that hit our nation
was the biggest challenge we faced
during peace time
and it impacted every family in our
nation I just want to to restate my
deepest sympathies and condolences to
all of those affected and on behalf of
the government to say that we want to
positively engage with this inquiry and
to learn the lessons that will come out
of it
thank you
Mr Darren you
have been Deputy Prime Minister since
April of this year
and since February you have been the
newly created Secretary of State in the
cabinet office
and since October of last year
Chancellor of the duchy of Lancaster
but you are not always so
because in
2018 you were appointed parliamentary
secretary for the cabinet office that is
to say the minister for implementation
and then in July 2019 you were appointed
to be Minister for the cabinet office
and then Her Majesty's paint Master
General
and so as Minister for implementation
and then subsequently as Minister for
the cabinet office
in a broad sense where the issues of
cyber and resilience
within your
barriers
portfolios yes that is correct
the inquiry has noted that as Minister
for implementation your responsibilities
included to cyber and resilience
whilst you were Minister for cabinet
office for the cabinet office and Her
Majesty's pay Master General your
responsibilities included resilience
and now currently as Chancellor of the
duchy of Lancaster your responsibilities
include concurrent risk and
supervision and the promulgation of the
resilience framework which we'll come
back to later
the ministerial structure appears to be
a little diffuse therefore in terms of
who takes responsibility for the issue
of resilience
can you help us please by way of
commencement on that point
yes
yes if I start with with the present as
it were which is where you ended Mr
Keith so um as Chancellor duchy of
Lancaster I have responsibility for
resilience and the Prime Minister has
asked me to chair the National Security
committee subcommittee on resilience so
I have oversight in that sense as well
and as
chance of Dutch of Lancaster indeed
Deputy Prime Minister I'm the lead
minister in the the cabinet office
and many of the cross-cutting and
coordinating functions of government
including in respect to resilience sit
within the department for which I'm
responsible in respect of my previous
ministerial roles I when I was first
appointed as a minister for
implementation as you say that's
parliamentary secretary so in sort of
governmental language that's the junior
Minister a junior minister in the
cabinet office I reported into David
lyddington who was then Chancellor of
the duchy of Lancaster so I had a number
of specific responsibilities allocated
to me and he in the same way that I have
now had oversight of the the department
so clearly I worked closely with him on
questions of resilience and cyber I
think on the point about uh cyber and
resilience and indeed many of the other
aspects of my portfolio then and now a
lot of them sort of Interlink with one
another in terms of the government's
cross-carting and coordinating role
through the cabinet office to enable
resilience so so cyber resilience is an
important part of resilience and in
discharging duties in relation to cyber
resilience and indeed wider resilience I
would draw on the government commercial
function of services had different names
over time and indeed the government
digital service and other aspects of the
portfolio
and and it in respect specifically of of
the differences
between the portfolios
helped by the minister of implementation
the Parliamentary secretary for the
cabinet office to which you were first
appointed and
the minister for the cabin office how
did those various responsibilities
concerning resilience differ was it that
the minister of the cabin officers was
more senior
but the minister of the cabin office and
the municiplementation covered broadly
the same ground
so first of all in respect of the
minister for implementation I was the
responsible Minister within a
ministerial structure where I reported
to the chancellor duchy of Lancaster and
he and I met and discussed it and he had
overall responsibility for everything
within the cabinet office portfolio in
including resilience and cyber then what
happened when Boris Johnson became prime
minister in I believe it was July of
he took the the decision that uh given
that we had to be prepared for the No
Deal uh it wasn't really a contingency
it was the default of of uh the the
government given that we'd uh made the
the decision to leave and we had this
this deadline that was going to expire
by the end of the year but we didn't
reach a deal with the European Union we
would have had uh no deal would have
happened so this was a major area that
we had to be resilient to so he he said
look I need the most senior Ministry in
the cabinet office who at that time was
uh was Michael Gove to take
responsibility for No Deal preparedness
as Chancellor seduction of Lancaster and
I want you Oliver as Minister for the
cabinet office to have responsibility
for all other areas in the cabin's
office which of course included cyber
and resilience so from that point
onwards Utah responsibilities Minister
for the cabin office for cyber and
resilience and you took that portfolio
in effect although perhaps not
um set out constitutionally in in
writing from the minister from him
from the minister from for
implementation
well I formerly you had as the minister
of implementation already being
uh
addressing the issue of cyber and
resilience yes so there was a continuity
in that sense of my responsibility for
cyber and resilience across to being
Minister for the cabinet office
clearly my role also expanded uh in
respect to the other ministerial duties
which are set out um in the some of the
the documentation that the inquiry has
the the only small habit I would add to
that is that
resilience and it was the most
significant resilience risk we faced
at that moment in respect of uh no deal
brexit sat with Michael Gove as chance
of the Dutch of Lancaster
all right thank you
um you made reference a few moments ago
to a subcommittee
the National Security Council
subcommittee on resilience
is that a reformed version of what was
formerly the National Security Council
threats hazards resilience contingencies
committee which to use a phrase
utilized by
um Miss Hammond miss Catherine Hammond
last week came out of the community
structure
is it a reformed version of that
committee or is it the same committee do
you know well it's it shares some
characteristics of of the previous one I
believe the shorthand of it this is the
throat committee uh in the sense so what
what is
different between the nscr and thrick is
that the nscr seeks to to take a more
Upstream view of uh risks and resilience
and look at
strategies to to stop uh risks
materializing in the first place so for
example we considered in a recent
meeting uh the biosecurity strategy
so it takes it it takes sort of more
strategic view in that sense it does
have the capability to make
cross-governmental decisions uh in
respect of specific risks and resilience
and so has that in common with with Rook
so it is it shares some of the the
characteristics of it but it is wider in
the way that I described all right and
is that the um the biosecurity strategy
that was I think published by the
government last Monday that's correct
yes all right
may I then ask you to give us a broad
description of the nature of your
functions when you first became Minister
for implementation
with particular reference of course to
resilience
you were responsible were you not for
the
civil contingency Secretariat that part
of the cabin office that was concerned
with
emergency preparedness resilience and
response
you presumably were responsible for
coordinating
through your ministerial position
eprr emergency preparedness response and
resilience across government the working
with other government departments that
the cabin office was centrally concerned
with the liaison through the cabin
office with the devil administrations
and local responders
and the policy and the guidance as well
as the strategizing
of which we've heard a great deal from
earlier Witnesses
so the minister for implementation was
responsible
through the cabin office for those broad
areas concerning resilience is that
broadly correct yes that's broadly
correct subject to to two points and
first of all I know that the inquiry has
discussed this um extensively but just
as a reminder from my perspective this
was in the context of the lead
government Department
model that is to say each of the 90 odd
risks that were identified in the nrsa
and the the the precursor documents of
the successor documents were allocated
to individual government departments the
the job of the capital office and as is
the case in many other areas was
coordination and facilitation and
ensuring that the bits of government
stitched together to ensure that that
happened that the second thing is again
further to what I said uh initially uh
that was in the structure where the
chance of the duchy of Lancaster had
overall responsibility for the cabinet
office and and I reported it into him
yes indeed and so the the cabinet office
had no operational responsibility in the
field of
resilience and emergency preparedness
its primary function was to set the
broad direction to deal with the
strategy the policy guidance and this
crucial liaison
between the various moving parts of the
government
the league government Department other
government departments default
administrations local responders and so
on
uh
yes that's correct and that that is a
sort of typical role of the cabin office
in many different areas and it was
replicated in uh the the resilience
function as well
in your witness statement you say that
you were brief that major programs of
work were underway to improve Readiness
across government for an influenza
pandemic
and that you would generally assured
that the government was reasonably
insufficiently prepared for an influenza
pandemic
may we presume that those briefings came
from the cabinet office by virtue of
your role initially as Minister for
implementation and then subsequently as
a Cabinet office minister uh yes that's
correct so um in common when most
ministers take up a new portfolio I sort
briefing across all the areas for which
I was responsible which included uh
resilience
um as I said the sort of 90 odd
resilience risks identified in the nrsa
I should say in addition to that there
are many other areas of resilience that
are not actually included within that
document whether it's sort of resilience
in terms of cross-channel strikes or all
the other sort of things that government
has to deal with
and uh clearly as part of that the I'm
sure the I know the inquiry is familiar
with the the way the risk Matrix Works
which is that uh we assess both uh
likelihood and impact and given that
pandemic flew consistently sat up in the
top right hand corner that was something
that I took an interest in along with
with other risks and so I asked for
further specific briefing on that
received that briefing and indeed
throughout my time as a minister
received further briefings all of which
were consistent uh
with advice that we were broadly in a
pretty strong state of uh preparedness I
relied for example on the international
service now I know there has been
questions and criticisms about how those
those worked but those were things that
uh that gave me assurance and indeed
there were throughout my time in office
I received further a piece of
information and briefing which
reinforced that that General picture
Deputy Prime Minister to what extent
when a minister receives briefings do
the briefings descend into the specifics
and the detail you referred to your
understanding of the the risk assessment
process for example
presumably the the briefings would have
covered areas such as the risk
assessment process the
the workings of the pandemic flu
Readiness board which was co-chaired by
the cabinet office and the dhsc
the
exercises the major exercises which were
being carried out by the cabinet office
for example exercise cygnus in 2016 and
it's aftermath
and and perhaps that the workings the
the most important workings of the dhsc
in relation to pandemic preparedness the
the pandemic influenza preparedness
program the PIP program
is that broadly correct that you would
have been aware of
the broad nature of the pillars of the
government's approach to pandemic
preparedness but not perhaps the
detailed
at a lower level
well first of all it would depend on the
the stage at which I was a minister so
when I was first appointed as as the
minister
you know I was I was told in Broad terms
you know this is the the resilience
architecture so we have the um nrsa we
have the Civil contingencies uh
secretary sits within the department
um we have the lead government
Department model also for example in
relation to to terrorism risks though
those are held by the uh by the home
office and the Home Secretary in respect
of um uh health and by security risk
broadly those were
held by the the Department of Health
I would then through a process of
iteration ask further questions about
specific areas
within that and then subsequently during
my time and in office as as issues arose
I would receive further briefing either
because there was a decision that had to
be made so I
um I had to agree and scrutinize and
sign off a particular document or piece
of cross-government working or because
there was something that was coming sort
of up as something that was moving from
risk to something that that may
materialize so for example that Ebola
was an example of something that we we
looked at during that time there were
many other examples and of course Across
The Wider resilience there was as is the
case most Winters there's there's
flooding there's occasional storms
there's all those sort of things that
require a degree of cross-government
coordination and a lot of what you do is
the minister for the cabin office or a
minister in the cabinet office is you
uh
you kind of just you need to know when
something remains with the lead
government department or if the leap you
often find a lead government will come
to you and say we need some help with
some cross-government work and you you
kind of supporting that way or make a
decision whether that was appropriate
for us or something that would infest
with the lead government department and
so as a minister
your plainly dependent on
anticipated risks and issues and
problems being brought to your attention
and you you can't be responsible of
course for every aspect of your
Department's operation
you won't know what all the
correspondence amounts to you are
dependent on the system
bringing matters which require
ministerial input to your attention
but in a but that that's not to say that
uh a minister is entirely passive in
this situation one sits there and waits
for officials to to bring stuff to one
so I uh I was very much engaged and I
know most of us often want for a better
word and The Wider sort of Civic society
and respect of that so just to give you
some examples uh frequently the
questions asked in Parliament whether
those were written or oral questions
would be select committee reports
produced the B independent bodies that
produce reports uh the media of course
would report on these things from time
to time so
pick up I believe they have those things
put in my book so I would see them or I
would independently pick them up and I
I'd walk into my private office in the
the morning or after the weekend with a
list of things that uh that had come to
my attention that that I wanted to
receive a further briefing on so it was
it was more of a
a sort of interactive process but
remember my responsibility
as as a minister was to to drive the
overall direction of the department I'm
not personally an expert in the details
of of any of the individual risks my my
job is to ensure that the the department
moves in the the right direction is
directed in the correct way and working
uh closely with the Prime Minister and
others to ensure that the the priorities
of the department and the conduct of
government reflects the the priorities
of of of the government as a whole
had evidence from
uh sort of a let win you you may have
seen the evidence I don't know but
he gave evidence about how when he was
appointed as a minister he he threw
himself personally into one or two
aspects or a number of aspects of his
Department
uh on account of his concern about
whether or not
um there were issues that were required
to be attended to and he called for
specific reviews of a number of areas
departmental areas
and carried out himself personally some
of those reviews
given
the sheer number of obligations within
the portfolio of the minister for
implementation and the minister for the
cabinet office
were you ever able to throw yourself
personally into that sort of review of
the field of civil contingencies
so so almost immediately after I was
appointed as
minister of implementation carillion a
major government supplier essentially
went bankrupt so there are immediate
challenges for me and I tended to lead
on it working with the chancellor Dutch
advances to ensure that we were
resilient and we responded to the
collapse of this major government
supplier essentially to ensure that
there was a continuity of delivery of
Public Services across the board
but also I was very mindful of the
resilience of the remaining providers
because uh I won't quote lady bracknell
but but uh yeah we didn't want to lose
another one let's put it that way so I
um so I spend a lot of time working
with officials both on the resilience to
ensure that if we lost another one we
would be resilient to it but also with
each of those strategic supplies to
understand pretty much on a daily and
then lastly a weekly basis the the
financial position of those strategic
supplies so I had a strong insight as to
what the risk landscape looked like and
then off the back of that I instituted
with the chance of Dutch and custero a
program of Reform of
um government procurement and the
approach that we took to our major
strategic suppliers so and there are
other examples like that what about in
relation to health resilience or
pandemic planning so the particular
field which of course this inquiry is
concerned
there wasn't the sort of
activity that I've described in respect
of
um carillion it was the case though two
things first of all
and I hope that the the documents of the
inquiry has demonstrated I was reassured
on a number of occasions and I know this
is subject to a subsequent debate by The
Inquirer and we can go over it in
hindsight but I was assured that we're
in a strong state of uh resilience for
it but in addition to that I did as
issues arose uh our specific questions
and and indeed seek routine updates as
well so for example
I asked to have a specific uh overview
of uh resilience Readiness across a
range of different issues that happened
periodically and I met with officials
periodically and I would periodically
pick up issues in that context
we're now going to look at some of the
documents to achieve referred Deputy
Prime Minister and and it's right than
in your statement you say that you were
brief that a major program of work was
underway and you were generally assured
that the government was reasonably
insufficiently prepared for an influenza
pandemic and you were broadly content
that the government was taking
reasonable and proportionate steps may
we please have 145720
this is a document
that you
won't have seen before this inquiry
because it wasn't sent to you it's a an
email from Catherine Hammond dated the
20th of September 2018 and it wasn't
addressed to you
but it's an email that concerns that the
general field of resilience and um
preparedness for pandemic flu
and it's an email within the cabinet
office
between the civil servants and the in
the cabinet office
concerning in September of 2018 so
um
when you were a minister a minister for
implementation
the priorities of the pandemic flu
Readiness board to which we'll come back
to in about which I know you're familiar
and at the bottom of the page
before the sign off before they uh the
penultimate paragraph there are these
words
messages to
the Department of Health and Social care
and cabinet office ministers and in
particular the chance of the duchy of
Lancaster as chair of the NSE
RC committee the committee to Virginia
flood earlier
given there are clear risks associated
with not taking forward the pandemic flu
Readiness board program
so it would seem from this
internal communication within the
cabinet office that officials
were considering the nature of the
message which would have to be sent to
ministers including yourself but in
particular the chancellor of the Dutch
in Lancaster about the clear risks
associated with not taking forward the
pandemic flu readiness
board program
so given your statement that you would
generally assure that the government was
reasonably sufficiently prepared and
that you were briefed that the
government was in a a moderately decent
position and that Readiness was being
improved
to what extent were you told at that
time September 18
that there were risks
in relation to the discharge of your own
ministerial role associated with what
was being discussed which was
not taking forward the program at all
for pandemic flu readiness
uh well first of all as you said I I
didn't specifically receive this uh this
email I I would
um take issue with the the point that
you're saying that not taking forward at
all because the um it was the case that
I did receive advice about some of the
reprioritization that was happening and
indeed I was specifically assured that
in respect of the two key areas that sat
specifically within the cabinet office
and if the inquiry will forgive the
terms is just it's just the the is the
wording that is used
um across government on excess deaths
that's to say the risk of increased
mortality that that work program uh
would continue I was also uh received
assurance that the pandemic uh flu Bill
uh preparedness would continue so in the
the advice that
how how this sort of transpired into the
advice that I received as a minister was
that reprioritization was happening
uh and we can come on to the if you wish
to the reasons for that we
re-prioritization uh but that in respect
of core areas for of pandemic food
preparedness in particular areas for
which the cabinet office was responsible
that work continued what I would also
say is that in the
it is the case that the the way the
resilience function works is it has to
have uh flexibility so
uh programs of workers are set out and
as different challenges uh face the
government we Flex uh resources uh
accordingly the key areas have to keep
on going other areas uh we reach a
certain state of of Readiness and then
we we resume them uh subsequently so
this was this was in the context of
uh what I was familiar with which is the
the constant flexing of resources
because bearing in mind we have
we were dealing with 90 or different
risks some of them were materializing uh
others weren't we we had to make
judgments across the board indeed
we of course are only concerned with the
risks relating to health emergencies and
including pandemic planning 145721
is a 10th of January 2019 submission
to David littington MP who was then as
your recall Chancellor of the the duchy
of Lancaster and therefore the senior
Minister you were at that stage still
the Parliamentary secretary and Minister
for implementation
this is a memo entitled delivery of NSC
that's the National Security Council
thrc the threats has its resilience and
contingencies programs and to remind
ourselves the NSC thrc committee was the
committee which was taken out of
community structure in
July 2019 when as his customary the
incoming government changed the
committee structures associated with the
cabinet and its subcommittees
delivery of work programs commissioned
by the NSC thlc on pandemic influenza
are expected to be affected by the Step
Up in planning for a No Deal exit from
the European Union
so
in a general sense although
the evidence shows that you're
absolutely right that some parts of the
work programs and some work programs did
continue
there was a general impact on the
delivery of the nset HRC programs as a
result of the re-prioritization of work
necessitated by planning for a new No
Deal exit
it's correct isn't it
hey yes what I would say is again
forgive me in the context of what I I I
said already namely that we had to
ensure that we uh allocated resources uh
according to where the greatest uh risk
uh lay now it was the case at that time
that no deal was the default position of
the government so it was appropriate
given and this is worth remembering the
the kind of frankly apocryphal warnings
that were being delivered about the
consequence of of No Deal uh
exits for example in relation to
Medicine supplies and and elsewhere it
was appropriate that we used we shifted
the resilience function to deal with
this secondly it was not a permanent
shift we knew that this thing would come
to an end since we had an end point for
if we didn't reach a deal no no deal
would happen the other point I would
make that it has come out I think in
some of the evidence is that
there was a flip side to this which was
that the the preparation particularly
through the yellow hammer
structures uh made us match fit uh for
when uh when we did have to deal with
the the actual materialization of uh the
the the the covert pandemic that is to
say it forced governments to departments
to work together closely so there's a
lot more cross-government
coordination and in addition
in relation to this we surged additional
capacity into the department I believe
we we recruited around 15 000 extra
staff who then were able to be
redeployed uh once the threat of No Deal
had passed in order to further step up
our preparedness for uh to to contribute
to our covert response
we were looking due course at the
undoubted benefits and there were
benefits from the planning associated
with planning for a new New Deal exit
but but in relation to a point if I may
observe that
the preparations were required but my
question was premised deliberately on an
acceptance that the preparations for the
New Deal
exit were necessitated and the lady has
the point already and it forms no part
of this inquiry to examine into the
worth of those preparations they were
necessary as part of the the plans for a
No Deal exit I mean what I would say
briefly on that is and I say this is
somebody who voted it myself really
litigated somebody who voted for remain
in the referendum there was another
question of one's view on uh brexit or
not it was just a fact that we had uh
triggered article 50
and that the default was that without a
deal we would have no deal so that that
was the default so it was really
incumbent on government and delivering
my duties in respect of resilience I
appreciated very strongly I had to make
sure that the United Kingdom was in the
best possible uh position as did every
minister to deal with uh with no deal uh
and actually in doing that as I said we
we did get some some uh other other
benefits from it but the reality was
that those preparations necessary though
they were
had a direct and significant impact
upon the majority of the work programs
to prepare for pandemic influenza
no I don't actually I don't fully accept
that so so uh the the core
responsibilities that suddenly I had in
respect of cabinet office in terms of
our areas under the pandemic fluid
preparedness continued namely the excess
deaths uh work and the the work in in
respect of uh pandemic flu Bill drafting
both of which by the way were then
subsequently the the learnings from that
were used uh when the covid crisis hit
us uh it was also the case that there
was this constant uh flexing that that
happened and when one takes it in the
round in terms of how uh it essentially
tested our ability to to work together
there's countless other examples of that
so for example uh the battle rhythm of
having these daily uh exos the fact that
we had a real-time data coming in and
going out again all of those things
actually put us in a position of of
being in a strong position and the
advice that I received uh was that the
core stuff that we had to do uh was was
continuing but in line with the normal
re-prioritization that that happens uh
for example when Salisbury hit there was
a reproditization I've just been dealing
with the um chairing the the cobras on
the the evacuation of British Nationals
from Sudan there's always there is
always a flex if we didn't have that
Flex We would we would not be in such a
strong position to to respond to to
challenges as they hit the government if
you look at paragraph two
of this memo addressed
to that your then Senior ministerial
colleague
recommendations that you agree that the
significant majority of the pandemic
influenza and
irrelevant and sensitive material is
then redacted due to report back to the
NSC thrc in March and February 2019
respectively are paused until the
completion of operation yellowhammer
Operation yellowhammer was the
operational name given to the
necessary preparations which were being
made for a No Deal exit
is it not uh yes that is Operation
yellowhammer and therefore that
paragraph States in terms that the
significant majority
of the pandemic influenza and
due to report back are paused so a
reference to the No Doubt to the work
streams or the preparations or the plans
a significant majority are paused so my
earlier question to you was is it not
right
that
there was a direct and significant
impact on the planning for pandemic
influenza as a result of the necessary
plans being carried out to deal with the
No Deal exit
so clearly I I by the way I I should
notice as you know that I didn't
actually receive this this specific uh
sub but the um I don't dispute the
pausing pointers is it is set out there
my the the area where I I just I take a
different view given my experience as a
minister at the time what's the point
about the the significant impact for the
reasons that I set out night I won't
reprise this but I would also say though
forgiveness it is worth viewing this in
the context of documents that I received
uh which gave me assurances that in
respect of uh particularly the cabinet
of this area for which I was responsible
that work was uh continuing so I I just
can't from my perspective that that was
not how it was at the time indeed
page three page two please of this memo
which
absolutely correctly
did did not go to you
paragraph eight says the government's
decision in December 2018 to step up
contingency planning
is placing unprecedented resource
pressure on both lead government
departments and the Civil contingency
Secretariat which is coordinating
operation yellowhammer across government
a number of departmental teams have
already been re-tasked with the majority
expected to follow over the coming weeks
civil contingency Secretariat is also
prioritizing operation yellowhammer work
and identifying non-time critical work
which can be paused accordingly
is that an accurate summation
as you understood it to be of
the consequences of the decision to
initiate operation yellowhammer
as far as you were being briefed
um
so I think
What in in some respects I would just
I'd just say two two other things which
is that and I won't reprise the point
about the um the normal nature of
flexing resources clearly this was at
the extreme end of flexing those
resources and that's that's reflected
there
there there is this is also the case
that when we Face challenges the other
thing we all do and uh senior ministers
ministers and certainly uh my officials
in my department is we just have to work
harder so uh we we try as much as we can
to walk and chew gum at the same time to
use that that localism but we
the the need to deal with the new
challenges our first recourse is just to
work harder and work longer hours in
order to to make sure that we continue
with the business as usual
course that we
have reflected in here
is to actively recruit additional
resource from outside government and and
that was the case I believe I think we
recruited around fifteen thousand uh
additional uh civil servants in into
government and I'm just sort of notion
passing that that game was additional
resource that was then uh subsequently
used when when when when when covert
struck so I just think it's in it's
important
to contextualize how this fits in with
the way in which government tends to
work
may we have please document 205-310
this was a a quarterly update
Deputy Prime Minister on CCS civil
contingencies activity which was
prepared in fact for you as the then
Minister for implementation and it's
dated January 2019 so
update for the minister for our
implementation January
and you were of course
still the minister for implementation at
that time because you remain so until
the 24th of July 2019. may we have page
two please
following cabinet agreement in December
we are prioritizing No Deal preparations
from now on this may include standing up
command control and coordination
arrangements for as long as required we
presume that's a reference to the No
Deal preparation Arrangements that would
need to be stood up
the Civil contingencies Secretariat will
continue a small number of essential
activities alongside No Deal
preparations but have paused all other
activity to enable sufficient focus on
preparations for leaving the EU without
a deal
that would appear to indicate would it
not
that in terms of weighing out the
balance of activities which were being
paused or ceased
the majority
of activities were paused to enable
focus on preparations for a new deal
exit and only a minority of activities
in the CCS continued for other matters
and well I think it's quite important
with this one I believe it's the
following slide actually makes reference
to uh pandemic flu preparedness it may
be the the the the one afterwards so
that was identified as an area where uh
where work could continue
so you'll see
further down the paid on this page a
reference to the emergency planning
College operations which was an antibody
to be prioritized and then the National
Security risk assessment completion
and and we know of course
that that risk assessment process was
um completed in 2019 so yes page three
there's a reference to pandemic flu
commitments close to completion
finalized including pandemic flu Bell
and excess death
guidance yes and those are the two areas
are they not to which you made reference
a few moments ago are they in the middle
of the page pandemic flu commitments
close to completion finalized including
pandemic flu Bill and excess death
guidance
yes and those those were the the two
principal areas uh which were allocated
to the cabinet office under under those
plan under under the the broader plans
of pandemic flu preparedness
but what about
all the other
pandemic flu related obligations and
recommendations which have come out of
exercise cygnus not just those relating
to the drafting of a pandemic flu bill
and the work streams relating to
excess death Guidance the two were
extremes to which you rightly have made
reference
so so this document and you you can see
from the the list of things is is
updating me on things that fell
specifically within my departmental uh
brief so the resilient satellite Network
at mobile alert and so on the clearly
under the lead government Department
model most of the activity identified
under
sickness to be taken forward fell to the
department uh dhsc Department of Health
and Social care so that's that sort of
separate to to this piece of work that
this is updating me on on my cabinet
office responsibilities
the pandemic flew bill and the excess
death's guidance were only a minority
were they not of the work streams which
were required as a result of exercise
cygnus and the pandemic flu planning to
which the government had committed
itself were they not
in in respect of my ministerial
responsibilities in respect of pandemic
flu we had allocated to the cabinet
office a small number of
responsibilities uh
the two most significant ones of those
were pandemic flu Bill and excess deaths
guidance there are a number of other a
large number of other
um uh areas of responsibility allocated
to
um to dhsc I don't believe that this uh
this deals with the what fell under dhsc
as the lead government Department
well there was a committee
to which you've already made reference
the pandemic flu Readiness board which
was co-chaired by the cabinet office and
the dhsc was it not yes I first of all I
think is
um I should say this was not a a
ministerial committee I sit on many many
uh ministerial committees and Boards
this was a cross-departmental
um operational board and though there
are many many such uh boards that bring
together officials so for example in in
the field of uh resilience for civil
nuclear disasters as one there's many
others of them uh I I was aware and
briefed of the the board but the key
thing for me was the output
and this this document reflects the
output out of that board did you as the
cabinet of his Minister from July 2019
have responsibility
for the pandemic flu Readiness board a
board which was co-chaired by your own
Department
so it was co-chaired by officials in my
department says I did not I never sat on
that board what the purpose of that
board was was to to deal with that cross
departmental working I was I was briefed
on the uh both the existence of the
board and you can see that in some of
the uh other papers and specifically on
the output of those uh of that board and
and this document in turn uh reflects
the the output of of that board and and
indeed I received other other briefings
that reflected the output of it and it
was it's a fairly uh common thing for
officials to get together in different
groupings to work through uh issues this
was a sort of um
sanding way of of ensuring that that uh
that that happened and then ministers in
turn were receive reporting out of it
odd was a board for the
cross-departmental working and output as
you describe it
relating to pandemic flu readiness
is that correct yes that's correct yes
and it is a board which was centrally
concerned with drawing up plans and
pursuing work streams related to what
was required to be done in relation to
prepare the country for
the ordeal of addressing a pandemic flew
yes that's correct yeah and it was a
board which was within your department
because it was co-chaired by it
to what extent
was the work of that board
as opposed to the general work of the
cabinet office
and this is yes to which this document
refers
interrupted by the necessary planning
that was required to be done for a new
deal exit
well I believe that the board uh
I think it met in
November 2018 is that I think that's
that's correct and then uh it
subsequently uh met uh
essentially after
uh yellowhammer has been stood down I
believe in uh November or December 19
and then in in January uh 2020 against
so may we take it from that that the
pandemic flu Readiness board did not
meet from November 2018
to November 2019. yes that's correct
were you told as the minister in charge
of
this particular aspect of the cabinet
office and as along with many others
that the board had not met for a year
and had been therefore unable to
consider in committee form the work
streams which were intended for it
uh
well
I I can't actually see from the
documentation that I have or the the
committee uh that so the inquiry has uh
I I can't see a specific
um document informing me of that I I
would expect that I would have been um
informed uh of it but the I think the
more for me the more fundamental point
is the minister was uh what are the the
outputs of this process so essentially
as you can see from that briefing I was
being assured that the core areas which
the cabinet office was responsible uh
were continuing I was also aware that
because of yellowhammer and I think that
was the right thing to do we were
prioritizing resources to make sure that
we were equipped for a No Deal scenario
and by the way if we hadn't uh done that
reprioritization would have been in a
much worse position to deal with covert
when it hit had uh no deal actually
occurred in terms of medicine supplies
and and so on and that this was part of
a normal re-prioritization
albeit I should say at the at the the
more uh sort of uh extreme end of
reprioritization given the the amount of
resources we had to dedicate to to No
Deal since it wasn't one sector specific
it cut across many different areas
is it is Extreme re-prioritization
um
a metaphor for
significant impact the
the reprodisation that took place here
Extreme as as you describe it
in effect meant that an important
committee dealing with pandemic flu
Readiness did not meet
and the majority of the work streams to
which the cabinet office prefer in a
general sense but specifically in the
context of pandemic flu planning were
interfered with they were either paused
or only part completed or stopped
altogether with the exception of excess
death capacity management and the
drafting of a pandemic bill
um
I don't think there's a great deal I I
can add to to what I previously I I I
disagree with the point about the
significant uh impact because of the
reassurances that I uh received and I've
made the point about how those pertain
to to the those specific recommendations
pertain to the cabinet office
uh it is the case that uh across uh all
government uh activity and bearing in
mind this is one of 90 odd different
areas of activity where uh
reprioritization I'm sure would have
happened across those risks and many
other areas
the assurance that I had and indeed
to my knowledge I didn't ever receive a
document and I I believe me as a
minister I frequently receive documents
from uh officials that say to me
minister
this is a major problem we need to do
something about it I I did not receive
that in respect of uh the situation with
the pandemic fluid the pandemic view or
there was a a an official level
cross-government coordination
um party
part of the uh the shifting of resources
to deal with this major challenge of of
no deal as it arose uh that didn't mean
that is not to say that activities
didn't happen quickly happened here and
also in respect of other areas that
they've been commissioned uh they
weren't sort of stood down they
they res as as it were we've made
progress in a lot of areas and in those
key areas for which I had responsibility
the the prioritization continued
all right thank you but ladies at a
convenient moment certainly I'm sorry we
have to keep you over lunch I know you
have so many things to do where we've
been hearing about some of the things
you have had to do but I'm afraid I have
to break regularly because the poor
sonographer has to cope with everything
we say and I gather you've still got a
little bit to go
not much but some
so I hope it's not too inconvenient and
I hope you can work in the over the
brick I shall return at 22. thank you
thank you
foreign
Minister before lunch you were giving
evidence about the pandemic few
Readiness board I'd like to take you
please to another pandemic flu Readiness
board document
23114 please
so the pandemic flew Readiness board
as we've seen was aboard
chaired in fact by the
cabin office and the dhsc it was a joint
board
and and therefore a board of course into
which both the cabin office and the dhsc
contributed this document is dated the
23rd of January 2020 so it's dated in
fact about three weeks before you ceased
being
Minister for the cabinet office
we can see it's a pfrb document because
in the top right hand corner
you will see the references the
reference to the board pfrb and what it
is is it's a dashboard of the work
streams coming out of the pandemic flu
Readiness board as at that date
the 23rd of January 2020. and I I'd like
you please Deputy Prime Minister to have
a look down
progress since the last meeting
which is the second column and the next
steps as well as the key risks in the
last column briefly in relation to each
of the each of the work streams
and
consider
the extent to which you were aware of
the progress
or lack of progress for for each of the
work streams
so the first one is Healthcare progress
has slowed due to Extended sickness of
the NHS England pandemic flu lead eux
and activities in the reorganization of
NHS England
in next steps draw a strategy to be
signed off consideration of the
communications further development of
the service facing guidance
lessons from EU exit planning will be
reflected and the key risks the
possibility of further major incidents
in London competing demands on key NHS
staff
NHS England and implementation
Improvement staff and NHS England
Improvement change of priorities
were you aware prior to leaving
ministerial office that
that degree of progress had been made in
relation to the work stream
of Health Care in relation to the
committee which the cabin office
co-chaired
well the first thing I I should say in
this Keith is clearly under the
um departmental uh lead model lead
Government departmental Model
these actions pertained to the
Department of Health so the my
expectations those would have been
reported through to the Department of
Health uh through their appropriate
processes
as I said in my evidence uh prior to the
the break the purpose of this board was
to bring together uh two different bits
of government at official level and I
would have been advised indeed was
advised on the the outputs as as we uh
discussed so I I wouldn't have expected
to have been briefed specifically on
this it could have been that I would
have done subsequently but given those
timings I suspect by the time we've gone
through the process of the board sitting
then the subs and so on advice come up
to ministers I doubt that would have
come across my my desk by the time I'd
I'd left
Deputy Prime Minister it's obvious that
not every document goes to the desk of a
minister and you've already made plain
that this is a committee
which was concerned with work streams
that traversed not just the cabinet
office but the dhse it was a joint
cabinet office dhsc committee and I I
believe other departments as well may
have had outputs from it as well they
may have had outputs but it was a
committee that was co-chaired by your
department
yes that's correct it was it's
co-chaired by officials in my department
chess and the pandemic flu Readiness
board was a board for which you together
with
the Secretary of State for the
Department of Health and Social care
took ministerial responsibility
uh yes it was it was a way of ensuring
that we had uh joined up and uh
government between different parts of of
the government machine Justice for
example in relation to say civil uh
nuclear preparedness that were there
were similar boards but this this was
about driving the the the
operationalization of of the direction
that the government was taking
number two were extreme Community Care
progress on the community healthcare
side has slowed due to Extended sickness
of NHS England pandemic flu lead EU exit
activities in the reorganization of NHS
England NHS Improvement
and then over the page please
excess deaths that is the work stream to
which you made reference isn't it this
morning yes that that was one that was
specifically allocated to the cabinet
office workshops have been held for body
disposal body transport body storage
coroners and prisons prisons was another
era that the cabin office was
particularly concerned with and that
appears to be a work stream that was
proceeded with but that would reflect
the fact again on the coordination and
facilitation role of government working
with
um with the ministry of Justice it would
have been at that time then over the
page please
sector resilience there's been no
further work on this work stream as the
statements preparedness are finalizing
was agreed that the sharing of the
business checklist should be paused as a
result of the need to communicate other
risks including EU exit
so sector resilience what is that
uh
so it's sort of what it says on the the
tin that is for uh different uh parts of
um society and the the nation their
ability to uh to withstand so for
example they might have the transport
sector you might have the education
sector it's it's it's chunks of the
economy and National Life
and resilience is basically yes
to to withstand yeah and again that
would reflect the fact that uh sector
resilience is something that cuts across
different parts of government so again
it goes back to this facilitation and
coordination But it includes Health
sector resilience of course uh
yes of course except except that what I
would say is that this is clearly this
is clearly dmop a health sector is the
the core sector for
um for the impact of uh pandemic flu so
uh it's sort of implicit in that is that
uh given the dhsc was jointly uh
chairing this board that that that would
uh sit with them I mean
so it's it's a sort of uh it is a
somewhat uh um academic distinction uh
in theory I guess Health would would sit
within it but but manifestly given the
actual facts of of where this
um how government worked together
given that that health or responsibility
you can see from many of these other
areas
I don't think we would have gone through
a process whereby it went
cabinet office
to health liaison engage given that
Health were already liaising and
engaging through this forum
well it was plainly an important work
stream otherwise it wouldn't have
appeared on the face of this document
also that that's uh but but the role of
cab reason I think cabinet office had
this allocated to it is the fact that
dealing with all the other government
departments that were not represented at
this board would have required the usual
role of cabinet office to facilitate and
liaise with them there wouldn't have
been a need for the cabinet offices to
facilitation lead with the Department of
Health since they were sat around the
table when they they went through all
these other actions the official the
only official whose name appears on this
document in the First Column is of the
senior resilience officer Emily Dibble
at the Civil contingencies Secretariat
within the cabinet office which was your
department yes that's correct right
number five cross-cutting enablers is
this a reference to the work that was
done on the draft pandemic bill
which in due course formed the basis of
the coronavirus Act of
2020. uh yes I think that is the case if
you look here in the the second column
across it says or all England Clauses
and supporting documentation including
explanatory note assessment notes and
assessment of impacts those are things
typically associated with the process of
drawing up legislation and we can see a
reference of legislative in the First
Column and also in the last column the
right hand column yes the future results
so maybe yes indeed a failure to
complete the bill all right so that's
that's one of the areas to which you
referred earlier which in relation to
which work continued and it was
completed and indeed that's reflected in
the over the page please
yeah
Communications
pandemic influenza public health
communication strategy content signed
off by the four United Kingdom chief
medical officers were extreme then
paused do you know why the work stream
is then paused
no I don't yes the the the short answer
I
calculate that um it was to do with our
previous discussion about operation
operations but I I couldn't say for sure
one way or the other then we've got the
moral and ethical Advisory Group
is that the group that was instituted in
order to be able to tackle the extremely
difficult moral and ethical issues which
might arise out of triage decisions
having to be made by hospitals in
essence
the Turning Away of patience for
treatment
uh
amongst other things yes so that so um
this arose from
a
consideration that uh government would
have to make difficult decisions and we
would have to uh
it would as again as the Titan suggest
it would give rise to moral and ethical
questions and we felt that it was
appropriate to have a body to help us
with that and indeed I signed off the
creation of the uh moral and ethical
Advisory Group uh as as a minister and I
believe certainly in a previous pack
there was a there was a sub that had
details and it had one introductory
meeting on the 25th of October
of
2019 and there was a debate about its
remit so that structure that committee
was set up and they had had one
introductory meeting
further down the page please over the
page
year two work streams
there is then a reference to this the
2011 UK pandemic influenza preparedness
strategy as it says the document dating
back to 2011.
the review was complete and commission
Center stakeholders
requesting relevant sections are updated
a number of updates are received have
been received not taken on board as work
stream paused aware of the need to
reignite this work stream
was that strategy document the 2011
strategy document the sole
pandemic related strategy document in
existence it relates to pandemic
influenza it was the only one related to
pandemic influenza and there was no
analogous strategy document for
non-pandemic a non-influenza pandemics
is that correct
um well I
I wouldn't imagine that that was the
case but I have to say I just want to be
absolutely clear with the um the inquiry
that even under the a lead Government
departmental model
these actions the ones that you can see
from my answers I'm able to to answer
very clearly on the ones that uh pertain
to Cabinet office responsibilities the
these pertain to Department of Health
responsibilities
the lens through which I saw all of this
was the nrsa and its successor documents
uh and ensuring that we had the
cross-government coordination indeed
this is reflected in this body meant
many other uh bodies so uh I'm sure that
was the case but I can't I can't say
that definitively uh to you because the
the strategies that I was concerning uh
myself with were all the things that
facilitator made government work
together and we we can see that more
recently with things like the resilience
framework the various iterations of the
standards that were required across
government the risk registers and and so
on it just as with the home office for
example when um you know home office
leads on counter-terror
I wouldn't tend to get to the detail of
each
being sort of um cognizant in the detail
of each individual strategy so that's
that's why I'm a little bit reluctant to
say but it
plainly it would appear on the face of
it so that would be the case as the
minister for the cabinet office and in
charge of resilience civil contingencies
the Civil contingency Secretariat and
the planning
cross-government through the cabinet
office of
pandemic influenza preparedness do you
recall whether you were aware of the
significance of that
2011 document
do you recall debate about that document
or the need to update it to refresh it
or was that something that just didn't
come to you as a Cabinet office Minister
I think that this this primarily sat
with the the Department of Health it was
their their documents in order to to
ensure the effective delivery of
government and indeed this is one of the
challenges that I find constantly as a
Cabinet office Minister it's to know
where to delineate the line between the
individual government department and
cross-government action and the last
thing that government departments want
is another government Department trying
to do the same thing as that department
indeed the purpose of this board
would partly have been to to deconflict
and to make sure like we're clear this
sits with one bit of government that
sits with another bit of government and
indeed that is reflected in the the
allocation of of work streams in the
First Column of this and indeed I should
say this is fairly standard modus
operandi of of governments that you you
have the overall uh Direction set
ministers are updated then you have a
minister asked questions and all the
other things that we discussed prior to
the break uh but then you have a sort of
a mechanism for making sure the two bits
of government work together and and this
is what this board was doing but Mr dad
the dhlc in the field of civil
contingencies and health emergencies is
the lead government department but the
cabinet office still retains its
obligation to ensure that
the wheels of government turn there's
proper coordination and liaison between
departments
and that all the moving parts
of the health emergency civil
contingency system continue to turn
the cabinet office at no time
absolved itself of the obligation to
ensure that the dhsc was on top of its
areas conservative civil communities in
the same way that the cabinet office was
on top of its own obligations and other
gub departments were
on top of their obligations
where is
the material which shows that
ministerially the cabinet office was
trying to drive this process forward and
saying there are gaps here there have
been pauses in the work streams we the
Civil contingencies Department must try
to resolve this
um well I think there's I sort of make
make two Reflections on this so
first of all this is important that we
have a lead government departmental uh
model and that each department takes its
responsibility and by the way it's not
as if this thing sort of sits there uh
that is a clear action that is allocated
to a senior uh responsible officer or
basically a lead civil servant in that
department they then fit in a structure
where they will no doubt report to a
director general or a
um probably a director general or a
director and then into a permanent
secretary uh those and then ministers in
that department have accountability for
that and oversee it and drive it the
separate role of the cabinet office is
is to say right how do we make sure all
the different bits of government work
together so for example if it was the
case that the Department of Health came
to us either at ministerial level or
through officials and said look we've
got a problem trying to deliver this
strategy we need to get
I don't know department for transport or
some other departments in order to make
this happen we're not getting the
movement we require then they would come
to officials in my department
potentially ministers would come to me
and say look
can you unblock this can you help make
this happen my first question would
usually be have you have you exhausted
all the things that you can do yourself
and if if you can't then we will use the
Machinery of government to help achieve
that what what is not a good use of
resource for us is to constantly uh
second guess things that are clearly
allocated to individual government
departments
but what about checking work streams
directly coming out of a committee which
your department co-chairs so if there
was a significant problem in respect of
this I would expect to be and frequently
was
updated remember this is a
non-ministerial board this is a an
official I would expect it to receive
advice uh to be informed that there was
a problem a there was a problem here and
B that it was a problem that required
cabinet office to uh to facilitate help
unlock and so on in the way that I've
described to you these problems did not
emerge for the first time on the 23rd of
January 2020 when were you therefore
updated and informed of the continuing
problems with this
process and the majority of the work
streams
I I can't recall now I'm sure it's
um it it would be in a one of the
documentation documents I would say I
don't actually recall in the documents
you've you've shown in indeed Mr Keith
I'm very happy to to look at it one that
specifically referred to to this point
the reason I ask is of course that in
your statement you say I was briefed
that a major program of work was
underway to improve Readiness across
government I was generally assured the
government was reasonably sufficiently
prepared for an influenza pandemic and I
was broadly content the government took
reasonably proportionate stats
commensurate with the perceived risks at
the time it is your assertions and your
witness statement
form the Genesis for questions about the
degree to which you were informed about
the problems a parent on the face of
this document yes and the the reason why
I
I said that is that and I can point
throughout the bundles that the doc the
the inquiry has uh where I am reassured
about the progress that that has been
made in respect of pandemic uh flu
preparedness and indeed if you go back
to one of these these previous sites I'm
not asking to scroll back up just recall
the at the time I received for example
the submission on the uh the the medical
uh ethical and Advisory Group that also
had a couple of annexes attached to it
which again provided updates and
reassurance indeed I believe in one of
the cells that I'm saying we are uh one
of the best prepared in in the world
secondly as we developed I as sort of
work streams uh shifted and adjusted in
the way that we were discussing prior to
the the break I received updates on
those so uh
that is the basis on which uh I I made
that assertion and remember of course
all of this is being done in the context
of the information that I had
at that time of course if you now
ask me with uh the Hinds on everything
that happened subsequently I can go into
to many discussions about uh
what what happened afterwards what I was
trying to convey in that that statement
was about my Assurance uh as to to where
we were at that point given the the
material that I've received as a
minister and all the information that I
had as a minister at that time this is
not hindsight is it
because this is a document due to the
23rd of January
produced while you were still a minister
on the eve of the pandemic
and these it's a reflection of work
streams that were running into problems
and being paused or stopped
over a matter of months in fact 18
months
prior to the pandemic
uh
well the first thing is that
as I said I didn't receive an update on
this I may well have received an update
and my answer to you may have been
different had I received that update
secondly this was the under a lead
governmental Department model one would
expect that those issues would primarily
be raised to the relevant lead
government Department which was the
department for health and indeed on the
the assertion that that these individual
things had that significant uh impact
subsequently again I've not I've not
seen the evidence of it no indeed could
we then just conclude this document by
just having a look at the bottom row
restructure of the online pandemic
influenza documentation guidance
this work stream was paused as a result
of EU exit if you just go over the page
we may see the continuation and
conclusion of the first sentence and the
first column
for government UK and resilience direct
and then the lrf pandemic flu standard
the consultation of the pan-free
standard which is a is that a testing
document for local resilience forums
that was completed
could we then look and you're quite
right of course
there were any number of documents after
the event
but they look backwards and they shed
light on the position prior to the
pandemic
um inq 57522
this was a a document which concerned
the implementation of the
recommendations that came out of
exercise sickness to which you referred
and and just to recollect the position
cygnus was an exercise in October 2016
was it not it reported in July 2017 and
thereafter over the following three
years work was done in order to
implement the recommendations from
operation from exercise cygnus
because exercise sickness was an
exercise in which the cabin office was a
participant organization
to what extent was a minister were you
informed about the progress being made
on the implementation of the
recommendations from exercise sickness
generally not just
those specifically concerned with the
cabinet office but generally as a result
of the exercise
uh well first of all I should say in
respect to this this document I I don't
believe I was presented with this
document the Department of Health
that's an important piece of context uh
for this document uh secondly the uh the
core role of the cabinet office in
respect of uh any exercise is to uh make
the thing happen so for example very
recently uh my department and I oversaw
operation uh Mighty Oak which was to
prepare us for uh the eventuality of we
uh lost power in the United Kingdom
something like sure we weren't worried
about as a consequence of it or we had
the appropriate actions so so that's
what the cabinet office was doing in
terms of pulling that uh together under
the lead Government departmental model
and I I have subsequently seen this
document you will see again in common
with the pandemic flu board uh
recommendations under each row there's
an allocation of those to each
government Department those that pertain
to the cabinet office again the uh I had
comfort that those uh uh were were being
conducted in the uh appropriate way
um it it was it was not the case and I
suppose this is the maybe this is this
fundamental point that you are guessing
it with with these questions that
um
I as a minister had 90 odd different
risks that uh sat specifically
identified in the nrsa uh within the
resilience portfolio in addition to that
there were many other risks that we had
to deal with uh
it
within that context
my responsibility was to make sure all
the different bits of government were
working together in terms of the overall
strategy not necessarily to to dive into
the the detail of each one of those 90
odd risks except if I was being advised
that there was a specific problem that I
uh that required my support in terms of
dealing with it in terms of how the
cygnus then came came through to this
that the outcome of sickness was then
embedded into actions that were being
driven through government so the
relevant ones the health department were
embedded into the health department and
as we've seen and we've discussed in
previous exchanges
those in relation to the cabin office
were embedded in the cabinet office that
excess deaths and so on
we can see from this document
that it refers to the fact that exercise
sickness demonstrated four key learning
outcomes the United Kingdom's
preparedness and response capabilities
and and of course you'll recall
that exercise cygnus reported that the
United Kingdom's preparedness and
response in terms of its plans policies
and capability were not sufficient to
cope with the extreme demands of a
severe pandemic
and the report was supported by 22
detailed lessons
this analysis mapped the 22 lessons
identified against policy and Planning
Development activities undertaken by the
whole of the United Kingdom government
and default administrations through the
pandemic flu Readiness board the body
chaired by the cabinet office and the
dhsc the pandemic influenza preparedness
program supervised by the dhsc normal
business as usual activities of those
organizations with the role in pandemic
preparedness
overall paragraph four the analysis has
found that eight lessons identified have
been fully addressed by the government
six lessons identified have been
partially addressed by the development
of new plans and policies but some work
is ongoing and work to address eight
lessons identified is still ongoing so
this is June 2020
almost
four years
three and a half years after exercise
cygnus
what you say about
risks outcomes work streams being
assigned to a particular government
Department
is well understood
but which government Department
stood back
and with an overarching eye asked the
question
what generally is happening with the
recommendations to exercise cygnus
to cover the possibility that each
department focus on its own
specific work streams and no one took
charge
to drive the overall process forward to
make sure that no one was falling
between two stools
so the the process by which this worked
was each one of those actions wasn't I
believe in the subsequent Pages you will
see it allocated to an individual
government Department
those government departments have
structures within them and I see it
within the camera's office to ensure
that they uh they did they deliver on
the areas for which they are responsible
so if you take those allocated to the
Department of Health there are senior
responsible officers who have
responsibility for those within the
Department of Health they sit within
reporting structures within the
Department of Health whereby they are
held to account for those those things
the whole purpose of having an SRO is to
say we're not going to have this
confusion this is the person to whose
name this particular responsibility is
attached now
in respect of those which were attached
to the cabinet office those were
um those were clearly addressed in the
way that we've discussed uh previously
in addition to that the facilitating
role of the cabinet office was to say uh
if the department came to us and had
problems with delivery of it they would
raise them in addition to that it's not
that that was the preponderance of had
happened but it was also the case that
there were many uh officials within the
the CCS they didn't sort of say
and there we are over you go and you
know forget about it there was an
ongoing uh dialogue but the
responsibility was very clearly set out
as set out in the different
um rows of that document all right may
we please have that document removed and
replaced by the resilience framework
for which
um
you you took responsibility you drafted
the forward to it
uh by virtue of
your subsequent
uh ministerial position as Chancellor of
the Dutch of Lancaster which post you
held from October 2022 and therefore
includes the framework document
97685 of December 2022.
do you recognize that document yes I do
I'm going to embarrass you Deputy Prime
Minister by asking you just to check
that the forward and the photograph is
indeed of of you and from you on page
seven
I'll wait for it to flash up on the
screen but there we are yes it's a
passing resemblance yes
this document
was a document prepared by the
government with obvious good sense in
light of
many of the Lessons Learned documents
which have emanated from the covid
pandemic
as well as
of course
the reviews carried out by various
departments concerned with civil
contingencies
and and also
it was a document promised in I think a
major Government Review in 2021 called
the integrated review of security
defense development and foreign policy
the inquiry would just like to explore
briefly some of the commitments which
have been made in in the in the report
because of course it forms no part of
this inquirer's functions I'm a ladies
functions to make recommendations which
have already been put into place or are
being progressed
so just briefly looking at the annex
which is I think is it um perhaps let's
start from page five which is the
executive summary
you can see there that the report is
divided up between the executive summary
and the action plans in relation to risk
responsibilities and accountability
Partnerships communities Investments and
skills and Annex B There is a summary on
page 66 it's it's page 72 online can we
have that please which sets out a
summary of the framework actions with
your report promotes
the first page of nxb deals with those
actions in respect which the you Kingdom
the United Kingdom government is already
taking action
so in relation to risk it's already
taking action by refreshing the nsra
process and indeed in 2022 the nsra
process was revised was it not to take
account of the possibility of multiple
scenarios yes that's correct and indeed
shortly we will publish them sorry to
get into all these acronyms but the
nrr which is the public facing version
the national risk register the public
facing emanation of the National
Security risk assessment and then
creating a new head of resilience so the
United Kingdom government's already
taking action by creating a new head of
resilience
may we toss you please with the question
has a new head of resilience been
appointed yes
and is that a post within a government
department or is it a post out with the
government Department it's a post within
a government Department it's a post
within the cabinet office so one of the
principal post-covered reforms we have
undertaken is to take the the previous
CCS so civil contingency Secretariat and
deal with one of the challenges which is
how do you balance dealing with
immediate crises as they hit whilst
continuing uh to ensure the The Wider
resilience uh picture so uh my Liberty
to name the might just help to to name
them by all means so uh Roger Hargreaves
uh now uh runs the Cobra unit that is
the crisis unit to deal with issues as
they uh immediately emerge so in the
short term so we don't lose sight of the
the longer term challenges and Mary
Jones uh overseas and is the head of uh
resilience they just in terms of the
overall architecture of the cabinet
obviously they sit in slightly different
reporting structures so so Mary uh sits
within and forgive me these These are
further details yes the economic and
domestic Secretariat which is the
overall cross government coordination uh
function Roger uh sits primarily within
the NSS the National Security secretary
which which reflects those slightly
different preponderances one is about to
join the uphold of government in the
form of resilience one is about the
immediate crisis response there was
before this resilience framework and
before the full terrible impact of
covid-19 became apparent already a
Director of National resilience in the
cabinet office a full-time job between
March 2020 and may 2022
to what extent is this new head of
resilience any different to the
pre-existing job of being Director of
National resilience in the cabinet
office so the the principal difference
is the split that I described to you
namely between the um uh ensuring that
we have both the focus on the uh
uh challenges as they hit the immediate
management of those and taking the
longer term risk and the the longer term
view also I would say uh the the other
thing that it does is and this this runs
through the the framework is looking at
how we try and prevent these things
happening in the first place so the sort
of strategies like the biological
security strategy uh actions in relation
to uh critical National infrastructure
resilience resilience to cyber uh Net
Zero strategies all of those
cross-government efforts that ensure
that these crises don't happen in the
first place as well as the resilience
for when they do
in relation to the new resilience
function in the third bullet point the
government's already taking action by
strengthening the United Kingdom
government resilience structures by
creating a new resilience function
before the split
in the Civil contingency Secretariat
between the new Cobra unit which is now
in the National Security Secretariat no
no so forgive me that so the the Cobra
unit is the Cobra unit it reports into
the National Security secretary it is
it is in the National Security
Secretariat and the other half of the
old civil contingency Secretariat is the
resilience directorate which is now in
the economic and domestic Secretariat
to what extent does this new resilience
function differ
from half of the old civil contingency
Secretariat namely the resilience
directorate which is now in the economic
and domestic Secretariat well I I think
one of the problems that we identified
previously and what we're seeking to
address with this is the tendency for
the the person that has overall charge
for this took to permanently be focused
on the immediate risks and not to take
that longer term View and I've actually
seen this in action both as a minister
before and afterwards I now have totally
separate meetings and regularly with
Mary Jones who is the the I'm proud to
him for now and the head of resilience
uh who is uh briefing me on where we are
with resilience and prevention whereas
Roger Hargreaves as head of cobras the
person that is uh briefing me and
ensuring that we are cross the immediate
challenges we Face such as uh you know
the Sudan evacuation was one of the more
prominent recent uh challenges that we
faced
so I think in that way you ensure that
one doesn't become the sort of poorer
relation of the other
page 73 please
the framework distinguished it does it
not between those steps in relation to
which the United Kingdom government is
already taking action and those
actions which the government is
committing to take by 2025 that's on
page 73 and page 74 by by 2030.
I want to ask you please about one
particular aspect of page 73 the the
roles
which will be put in place by 2025
halfway down the page Partnerships
because
the degree of external review of
challenge
of
advice antithetic to groupthink is an
important issue for this inquiry
the government
has agreed to commit to Growing the
United Kingdom's advisory groups made up
of experts academics and Industry
experts in order to inform the nsra this
may include establishing a risk-focused
subgroup of the United Kingdom
resilience forum
in drawing up the report Deputy Prime
Minister what did you have in mind in
relation to what those external experts
academics and Industry experts might
consist of given that the report in its
body makes playing
that Sage will continue to play a vital
role
the United Kingdom resilience forum is
already set up
the provision for a body called s-tax
will continue to provide expert advice
and that the government will actively
and regularly draw on Expert challenge
do you know what exactly is in mind in
terms of growing those groups rather
than relying upon the existing
structures
there's a short answer in there a long
answer to give you the long answer I'd
have to go through each of those
different bodies that you listed and
explained you the specific functions the
short version of that is that I don't
believe that any of those uh bodies
perform specifically the function of uh
an external uh look and challenge across
resilience so just to take one uh Sage
was particularly in relation to to
biological security risk in particularly
in the the health sector they wouldn't
have much to uh say or think they'd have
anything to say in in relation to a
severe a terrorist uh incident they
might have something to say in in
relation to say civil nucleus so the the
idea is to to create some some further
external Challenge and indeed for me as
a minister and I'm I'm there's a
conversation with other ministers and I
think you've probably heard in evidence
and I saw briefly in the evidence of Sir
Oliver lepwin
one of the most important challenges for
us as a ministers is to know what the
right questions are to ask in the first
place and the more Divergent forms of
opinions and Views you can get the
better able you are to to ask the right
questions so within this um resilience
Forum which as you said earlier I I
chair I think there's uh there is value
in trying
to take so the resilience form at the
moment is about kind of pulling together
as it were all the different strands in
line with the whole of uh Society
approach that's outlined in the uh this
strategy that would be about providing
the sort of challenge inward as it as it
were
and so I think there is value in doing
that although what I would say that I
have you know I've tried to keep up to
date as much as I can with the
deliberations of this inquiry and I
think some valid points have been made
about other routes for finding that uh
external challenge so we'll certainly uh
look to the outcome of module one to see
see what uh your recommendations are in
that respect
thank you very much
Miss Dunn um as far as the head of
resilience is concerned what level of
official is it
she she is a director
and she reports to a minister in the
cabinet office that happens to be you at
the moment or to the Deputy Prime
Minister if there is one to whom does
she report efficiently she she reports
to uh well she's available for all all
uh ministers to meet with but she will
report uh to me not Deputy Prime
Minister's sort of to to one side as
Chancellor the duchy of Langston
Chancellor the Dutch anger is that is
the lead minister in the department and
indeed I meet very regularly with um
with with Mary Jones as you might
imagine
given the number of responsibilities
that um you referred to in very briefly
and I heard from Sawyer letman
do you think there may be an argument
for saying that there needs to be a
minister whose specific responsibility
is resilience
and I think it's a very interesting uh
argument and I yeah
I saw all of his evidence quite quite
late last night so forgive me if I I
didn't catch every Nuance of it but um
I can see the argument he's making the
thing I would just say to consider on
the the other side is twofold first of
all if you try and pull out resilience
from all the other cross government
coordination that happens in Cabin
office I think you'd lose something from
that so for example I'm able to link
across for example the intelligence I
receive on the NSS side in terms of uh
malicious threats and indeed that is
very relevant to resilience now in the
context for example of the Russia
Ukraine developments that we've seen
over the past year or so I'm also able
to link it across to the government
commercial function which which sits
within the within my department and they
in turn link through to the each of the
commercial functions departments so you
I don't if you took all of it and
transferred it across you basically be
saying have me I I as it were and I I'm
I think that uh on balance it probably
works better to have a a senior Minister
and I'm fortunate enough to have been
the point of senior Minister now uh
overseeing all this to the to the other
point that Oliver made but I think he
made the point about having the prime
minister's ear being able to uh
influence the the would inevitably be a
very limited number of ministers who
were able to have that kind of access to
the prime minister so you may well find
that there could be a a trade-off there
not not necessarily but I would just be
concerned about how enduring that would
be so it could well be the case that
when the minister was first appointed
they would be somebody that the Prime
Minister you know knew well and placed a
lot of trust in you could find over the
course of uh reshuffles they became a
less significant Minister it is always
the case that the cabinet office is a
core government department and the role
of the chancellor deductive Lancaster
certainly for the past 20 or 30 years
has tended to be held by senior Minister
and I I think that that would be the the
thing I would weigh up in uh
considerations
one last question you've said a number
of times as is bound to be the case that
you rely on assurances that you get and
briefings that you get from officials
how do you as a minister make sure that
um they're not marking their own
homework
it's it's very good because it goes back
actually to the the the the the last
exchange which is about one of the
biggest challenges as a minister is
knowing the right questions to ask so
all ministers rely on external uh input
uh I I would say external input I rely
on is first of all think tank reports
reports from
um all the numerous learned institutes
questions that opposed to me uh in
Parliament
um I shall
have the drive of questions in
Parliament tomorrow on on the cabinet
office and I will make sure that I'm
across all the issues that are going to
be raised there that will almost
certainly give rise to some external
challenge which I then put back into the
system it's also the case that there is
from time to time quite considerable
media interest in it I will always make
sure that you know if I'm going to be
questioned on these things I know uh
where we are and when I get the
responses I will frequently say well
hang on how does that thing match up uh
with the other thing I I've always taken
the view that I I welcome
more external challenge I think a
diversity of views and opinions helps
make for more robust decision making and
a minister that's empowered with a
greater diversity of ideas is able to
better perform as a minister
thank you very much
Mr Steve my lady there are no questions
under rule 10-44 which you've granted
permission so that concludes the
evidence of the Deputy Prime Minister
thank you very much indeed Deputy Prime
Minister
ing the inquiry thank you
my lady the
next witness is the chancellor of the
exchequer
we're going to have to break obviously
in the middle so yes can you
we started at ten to two
the break would probably be at about
five past temper sadly my lady
yes please
I swear by almighty God
that the evidence I give
the truth shall be the truth which
the whole truth
and nothing but the truth
would you be good enough to give your
name please Jeremy Hunt
Chancellor thank you very much for
providing your assistance already to
this inquiry by virtue of your witness
statement which we'll see at
177796 dated the 4th of April 2023
if we could have the last page page 17
would you just be good enough to confirm
that that is the statement of Truth and
declaration to which you appended your
own signature it is
um
for the purposes of my lady's inquiry
most pertinently you were Chancellor
went to Secretary of State for health
between the 6th of September 2012 and
the 8th of January 2018
and thereafter the Secretary of State
for Health and Social care until the 9th
of July 2018 when you became Secretary
of State for foreign and Commonwealth
Affairs correct
you will also although plainly not a
minister chair of the Health and Social
care select committee between January
2020 and October 22
at which point
perhaps a couple of days earlier or a
couple of days after you became
Chancellor of the exchequer correct in
which post you continue to the present
day
Chancellor it is obvious that as
Secretary of State for the Department of
Health and then the Department of Health
and Social care
you were keenly aware
of the onerous obligations placed on
your secretary of state in relation to
the provision of health care including
the obligations associated
with the DH and then the dhsc being the
lead government department for pandemic
risk
being a health emergency correct
and it is clear from
the documents before the inquiry
the departmental risk register
the paperwork and guidance relating to
the discharge by your department of its
role as lead government Department
the legal obligation
placed on the department by virtue of
being a category one responder of the
Civil contingencies act 2004
and its supervision
of
a number of bodies but most importantly
the pandemic influenza preparedness
board
and the co-chairing of the
pandemic flew Readiness board
that pandemic planning lay at the heart
of your Department's work correct
I want to ask you please
in light of that
about exercise sickness which was in
October 2016.
it was an exercise which took place
between the 18th and 20th of October
and it was an exercise which was
reported upon in July of 2017 the
following year
you were of course Secretary of State at
the time
to what extent do you recall the
significance of exercise sickness
or the recommendations that came from it
well I recall taking part in the
exercise extremely well
um why why was that because it was uh
not just a significant chunk of time
taken out of my diary but because
[Music]
um
something quite traumatic happened in
the course of the exercise even though
it was only an exercise
um
which caused me to stop the exercise I
was basically asked in the course of the
exercise to
sanction the
um
the emptying of all the Intensive Care
beds in the country leading to the death
of numerous people in those intensive
care beds
on the grounds that
the nursing requirement for those people
in intensive care
was so big because each intensive care
bed needed three or four nurses to look
after one patient that those nurses
could spend say more lives if they
operated in the community this was a
hypothetical cool yes just in case
anyone's switching on at this stage yes
um and
um
so effectively I was being asked to
flick a switch which would have led to
instant deaths and um I wasn't prepared
to do that
and um rightly or wrongly you could
obviously argue it lots of different
directions but you know
benthamite terms the greatest good for
the greatest greatest number perhaps I
should have been prepared to do it but I
wasn't prepared to do it and I think
that for the people and that was I think
for the participants quite a
controversial moment
um and thankfully it was only an
exercise but
my judgment was that it was that any
pandemic scenario if you were asking a
human being
how many politicians are of course human
beings to make a decision like that it
was fought with risk and danger and I
personally would have felt very very
difficult taking that decision and so we
develop new protocols as a result of
that which meant that I think in that if
that situation would happen in real life
the secretary would not be asked to take
that decision and you made it plain that
that was an intolerable decision to have
to take for any Secretary of State and
there had to be an alternative course
and you directed that protocols be drawn
up to to deal with that possibility
correct and we have to be honest that
you do have to take those decisions in
one way or another when there's limited
capacity and you know when we saw the
covert scenes um in Lombardy
there were absolutely heart-wrenching
scenes of Italian doctors saying that
they're being asked to play God because
the people they were depriving of a bed
would inevitably die so it isn't that
you can't duck those decisions but what
I felt was inappropriate was those
decisions being taken at such a long way
away from the front line and I thought
those decisions if they have to be taken
need to be taken by people who are
familiar with what's going on with
individual patients and so I'm not at
all suggesting that um
that there aren't incredibly difficult
things you have to decide in any
pandemic but it's just that it felt too
clinical to me that that should be
surfaced in the so almost like a regular
ministerial decision this is what you do
at this point uh when the human
consequences were so striking and
although it's not a matter for direct
inquiry today
it's out with the scope of the errors
which we've we've asked you to assist
but
in part as a result of that terrible
conundrum you were faced with
was they put in place a body called the
moral and ethical Advisory Group to deal
with
the worst types of moral and ethical
decisions which might confront clinical
staff and administrators in the event of
a pandemic
that may well have been what happened I
wasn't aware that was the the
consequence but what I was aware of was
this Dreadful euphemism that was used to
describe that decision it was described
as population triage which
um
essentially was a nice way of saying
making life or death decisions about
large numbers of people in one go
there there could therefore have been no
doubt in your mind as to the
significance of exercise cygnus which
was
I think across government exercise it
was commissioned by your department then
the Department of Health
to test the United Kingdom's response to
a serious pandemic
influenza
do you recall what the general outcome
was of exercise cygnus Chancellor
um I do and I would say that I think
there is quite a big misunderstanding
about exercise cygnus
um which is that certainly as it was
described with me it wasn't an exercise
that was to examine the UK's
preparedness for pandemic influenza it
was to establish how good the UK how
well the UK would COPE in a situation in
which pandemic influenza had already
taken hold so the the starting point of
the operation was we had already had
between two and four hundred thousand
fatalities and I think 1.2 million
people infected with pandemic flu and so
it was to see how our systems would COPE
in that state of extreme pressure
and I know you you may well want to talk
about the issue of group think but I
think this was the first example looking
back with the benefit of hindsight this
was not what I thought at the time and I
you know with retrospect of course I
wish I had challenged at the time but
there were no questions asked of any
stage as how do we stop it getting to
the stage of two to four hundred
thousand fatalities it was an assumption
that if there was pandemic flu it would
spread using layman's terms like
wildfire and you pretty much couldn't
stop it and this was how would the
system COPE in that extreme situation so
that's why rather ghoulishly when you
read through the
um report of the exercise there was lots
of talk about Mortuary capacity and how
you would deal with so many dead bodies
it was that kind of thing and and as far
as the NHS and care system was concerned
um how you deal with so many members of
Staff being off sick even if not fatally
off sick
we'll come back to this later but
on the issue of of group think
it may not have had its Genesis solely
in the exercises which made assumptions
of course about numbers of deaths
it may have added Genesis also in the
risk assessment process which made
assumptions about huge numbers of
fatalities it may have had his Genesis
in the integrated management structure
IEM for dealing with civil contingencies
and emergencies which again
perhaps fail to focus sufficiently on
preventing
devastating consequences as opposed to
dealing with them
but exercise sickness what was a seminal
moment wasn't it because it it was
designed as you say to test the United
Kingdom structures for dealing with a
severe pandemic
and
no doubt you you and your department and
not least yourself because you had had
this personal involvement in the
exercise what we're concerned about the
conclusions of exercise sickness
do you recall
prior to the report being published into
exercise sickness internally I should
say it wasn't publicly made available
in July 17 whether you were briefed as
to the general conclusions
of exercise sickness
I don't recall any particular briefing
but I had a very close
and productive working relationship with
Dame Sally Davis and I'm sure that she
would have talked to me um a lady is has
heard that that evidence
um and would have kept me abreast of her
thinking I mean in some ways I worried
about the fact that I was not prepared
to flick the switch I'd sort of let the
side down in terms of this exercise
because I think there was
I felt a sort of expectation that they
would need someone to take those kinds
of decisions so I'm sure we would have
had a dialogue about it in your witness
statement you you do say the insights
from the exercise and and its
recommendations were were made known to
you
the point I want to ask you to to focus
on however is to what extent were you
aware of the
insights and the recommendations in
advance of the formal report being made
available there was a considerable
interregnum between the report the
exercise in October 16 and and the
report becoming available in July I
doubt I would have been in made aware I
think it would have been produced at
arm's length from me
um and then I would have seen it all
right
you attended Chancellor a a meeting of
of the committee That Was Then in place
called The NSC the National Security
Council
thrc threats hazards resilience and
contingencies ministerial committee
in February of 2017 so after cygnus but
before the report and it was a a meeting
chaired by the then prime minister
Theresa May MP
may we have that on the screen six three
five seven
there we are those are the minutes of
that meeting held in the cabinet room at
number 10 on Tuesday the 21st of
February at 2PM with the
minister in the chair and and we can see
your name of course Chancellor and the
bottom right hand corner at sector state
for health
and if we go over the page please
we can see the remainder of those who
attended
and then on Page Six
the second paragraph the Secretary of
State for health said that
contrary to the image presented in the
media the National Health Service was
extremely good at responding to
emergencies this was in part a
reflection of the important contribution
of the chief medical officer
then Professor Dame Sally Davis and
colleagues who worked in public health
exercise cygnus have been a significant
test of the country's Readiness for a
severe pandemic influenza strain hence
your observation that sickness wasn't
concerned with a general
pandemic he was concerned with a severe
pandemic influenza strain
and and there were three important
lessons to learn
first the plans for responding to an
influenza pandemic should reflect the
need for decisions to be taken to the
right level
was not appropriate for the government
to interfere with local clinical
decision making concerning access to
hospital care second the preparation of
a pandemic flu bill
would help to take the various
legitimate measures to streamline and
augment capacity in health and other
services third the country's capacity to
manage excess deaths needed to be
improved
there is in that paragraph therefore
Chancellor references to the work
streams which
continued thereafter and Milady said
evidence about how the work streams in
relation to the pandemic flu bill
reached fruition and the work stream in
relation to excess deaths that that
terrible euphemism for the frankly the
sheer number of deaths that would result
from severe pandemic
and how that work stream would be
managed
the conclusion from exercise cygnus was
that the United Kingdom's preparedness
and response in terms of its plans
policies and capability were not
sufficient to cope with extreme demands
of a severe pandemic
so the question Chancellor is this
in this paragraph you refer quite
plainly to the lessons that needed to be
learned and to the fact that cygnus was
a test of the country's readiness and to
a particular number two in fact work
streams
to what extent was the NSC thlc
committee made aware of the overall
conclusion of cygnus which was that the
preparedness and response in terms of
the whole of the United Kingdom's plans
policies and capability were not
sufficient
to cope with the demands of a severe
pandemic
I think
um
so we were this paragraph
is obviously not what I would say now
with the benefit of hindsight and having
gone through the pandemic I want to
answer your question exactly so just
forgive me if I take a moment to to
explain
um
the issue what we thought we had learned
from cygnus was that
the country wasn't very good at coping
with a pandemic where hundreds of
thousands of people were going to die
because we didn't have the Practical
Arrangements in place to deal with the
dead bodies we didn't have the
decision-making structures in place that
would need to do population triage to
use that euphemism and we didn't have
the legislative requirements in place to
pass a law quickly through the House of
Commons
and so
all those things are true within the con
if you ask the question as narrowly as
we did in cygnus which is how well
prepared are we for this particular
situation when two hundred thousand plus
people have already died a million
people have already got the virus
um what we didn't ask and this was this
was the mistake was first of all is it
only pandemic flu that we're likely to
be hit by
um and could there be something with
mers-like characteristics that are
respiratory virus that spreads almost as
fast as flu but has different
characteristics we didn't ask that
question and we didn't ask the other
question which was
um what could we do to stop it getting
to that point where 200 000 to 400 000
people have died so I think within the
narrow confines of the question we asked
we came to the right conclusions the
government accepted the 22
recommendations from memory they weren't
all implemented but um
unfortunately even if we had implemented
them all I don't think we were asking
the right questions
and you said you promised us that you
would
return to the precise question after you
had given that
General
explanation which was why is there a
a difference seemingly between the
the description of the
important and significant
outcome of exercise sickness given in
that meeting and the overall conclusion
itself on the face of the report which
hit the nail on their head by saying
across the United Kingdoms the plans the
capabilities and the abilities are not
sufficient because what we meant by that
sentence was our plans and capabilities
in that very specific situation where
you've been hit by pandemic flu and
you've had two to four hundred thousand
fatalities if you
what we should have done is thought much
more widely about the question in the
way that that sentence can be
interpreted to me but that wasn't how
we interpreted we thought that we had
very specifically looked at this
specific scenario and we did and we
addressed the weaknesses in our
provision
but we should have been asking a
different question in the first place
could we have please one eight seven six
nine four which is a health sector
security and resilience plan produced by
your department then the Department of
Health
page three
the first paragraph says under the
executive summary and this is a document
wasn't it which
huh what was prepared in the in the
general field of resilience planning for
for the health sector within the health
sector there are generally good levels
of resilience with good preparedness and
business continuity Arrangements in
place
on the face of it
that that would appear to give a
different impression to the conclusions
the very clear conclusions reached by
operation exercise sickness
which was that across the board
there was a significant failure in the
planning the capabilities the abilities
of the United Kingdom to deal with a
severe pandemic
um well as I say I think that operation
cygnus was had had a very a narrow focus
of too narrow Focus I think um so could
I just ask which date this document is
chance I'm going to say and I I'm
obviously not permitted to give evidence
it's a it's a very good question I don't
believe that on the face of the document
we're able to give it a date
but we believe it is after exercise
sickness
right and presumably when I was still
Health secretary oh yes it's it's at
that time okay it's not a document from
years later okay I mean
that first uh sentence we know is wrong
and
um you know um but I'm I'm afraid this
was also I'm sorry to keep going back to
this but this was also part of the
mistaken assumption so alongside this
assumption that it was going to be more
likely to be a flu that we had to deal
with than a
um an emerging respiratory virus which
would have many fewer casualties there
was another assumption that we were very
good at dealing with pandemics and
um we all thought it
um and by the way it wasn't just us you
know Johns Hopkins University in America
said that the UK was the second best
prepared country in the world in the
global Health security index in 2019
and they had sub-categories and one in
this one of their subcategories was
which country is best prepared for
preventing the spread of a virus and
scaling out treatment quickly and we
were top we weren't second best we were
top
um so there was I think a completely
wrong assumption and I think that
the truth is we were very well prepared
for pandemic flu because we'd be given a
lot of thinking to it you know operation
sickness exercise cygnus was a huge
thing
um but we hadn't given nearly enough
thoughts to other types of pandemic that
might emerge and and that was
with the benefit of hindsight that was a
you know a wholly mistaken assumption
and I think that
um
item number one demonstrates that
the same John Hopkins Center report
a report from the same John Hopkins
Center
in December of 2019 warned in the
clearest terms
of the dangers of focusing to
march on a pandemic influenza and
ignoring the significant risk
of a different viral pandemic with
different characteristics including a
longer incubation period
asymptomatic transmission higher
transmission and deadlier severity
so that was probably another instance
was it not of the group think we should
have absolutely and and that same John
Hopkins report also said no country was
well prepared even though you know the
US and the UK it said were the best two
prepared it was it was very clear
that no country was was well prepared
would that be sensible yes thank you my
lady
sorry we have to break off
um Mr Hunt but I have to think of other
people including our very hard-working
stenographer
um will ensure that we get through your
evidence today so that we don't impose
even more upon the brothers of
government so thank you
foreign
to a different topic and the important
question of the United Kingdom pandemic
influenza strategy document 2011.
there was only ever one Department of
Health strategy document relating to
pandemic influenza and it was this 2011
document and there was no analogous
strategy document dealing with a
non-influenza pandemic or a range of
pandemic scenarios or or even
generically a non-influenza pandemic
can you recall
to what extent you were briefed or
informed that that strategy document of
2011 required
refreshment being refreshed and as the
terminology appears to describe it being
updated
I don't recall ever being advised that
the evidence shows that it was due to be
refreshed to use the departmental phrase
but but that in 2018 and 2019 that work
was paused
as a result of operation yellowhammer
to which will come later
in the context of pandemic influenza
planning
a a failure to update the soul and major
strategy document
between 2011 and 2020 is a matter of
some regreters and all
I think there was a a much bigger
failure which was that we were over
focused on
pandemic influenza and I would say that
um
notwithstanding the fact that I don't
believe I was ever advised that we
should update that 2011 document I
became Health secretary as you know
towards the end of 2012.
um we did spend a lot of time thinking
about
um dangerous viruses because
um at the end of 20
14 we had the Ebola
virus which we were very directly
involved in and um
as a G7 Health Minister I went to a lot
of summits where we discussed the global
response to Ebola
and you know we had Global Health
security summits I organized one in
March 2018 so there was and we had
exercise cygnus as well
so there was a
quite a lot of thinking but I think
looking back on it
it's very clear that it was very deeply
entrenched almost visible in every
single document relating to this that
you can see that there was an assumption
that a mass fatality pandemic would be
flu
and I think you're going to come on and
talk about exercise Alice which yes I
wasn't briefed about which which itself
is telling that I was you know asked to
take part in exercise I never I don't
know if it's exercise sickness or
operation sickness but that was a
mistake of mine it is exercise Signet
and exercise cygnus and exercise allies
right thank you for for letting me know
that but you know I wasn't briefed about
exercise Alice I was asked to take part
in in exercise cygnus
but I think it's just interesting when
you look at that that that is the report
on exercise Alice is literally the only
place
that I can find which really talks about
the importance of quarantining and if
you look at the
this assumption that you can't stop the
spread of the virus
I think that was deeply entrenched when
uh when covert arrived
um and we didn't look at countries like
South Korea and Taiwan which had a very
different assumption about the
effectiveness of quarantining so that I
think so it's updating a pandemic flu
document of course all things being
equal it would have been a good thing to
do
but the fundamental issue is that we
would by the way not just us but across
Western Europe and North America
there was a shared assumption that
herd immunity was inevitably going to be
the only way that you contained a virus
because it spread like wildfire it was
perceived the outbreak of the covert as
a rather heartless approach but that
wasn't really
what it was it was what scientists
thought was unfortunately what was
inevitable all those assumptions would
only have been challenged if we'd had a
document that looked at all pandemics
not just pandemic
but to be clear it wasn't a pandemic
influence a strategy document it was the
only
Department of Health pandemic influenza
strategy document yes and it was the
only pandemic document but it just
happened to be about pandemic flu
the inquiry does not exist to
to find fault solely of course
you've referred to the meetings that you
organized
uh it's right that I point out
that based on your witness statement you
took a
a number of very important steps when
taking ministerial
office you organize meetings of
international Health ministers to raise
the alarm
concerning the risk of a severe pandemic
and and would you just tell my lady what
was done in relation to the the setting
up of the UK VN that the United Kingdom
vaccines Network after the Ebola
outbreak to which you've just made
reference which was in 2014 and 2015.
yes I mean I don't
know actually if it was my direct
ministerial decision but it was a
decision of the government following the
Ebola outbreak to set up the UK vaccines
Network I think chaired by Chris Whitey
yes
um
and I think
um you know that obviously
was fundamentally very turned out to be
very important historically because that
was the basis upon which the
Oxford AstraZeneca vaccine was developed
which
saved more lies than any other vaccine
in the pandemic across the world I think
about six million lives in total
and I think that is interesting because
although we had a blind spot
about flu being the thing we needed to
worry about
with flu a vaccine is very important so
if you like the other side of that coin
was that right at the start of the
pandemic we were one of the first
countries that really were thinking
about vaccines
and charging ahead with vaccines which
we did faster than pretty much anyone
else which is why we made such a a lot
of progress
but I think
Professor Whitty deserves enormous
credit and
certainly not under any guidance
from us as politicians because of the
scientific way that he plotted
the development of that vaccine's
Network such that it was actually able
to turn into something as significant as
it did and and so then the lady can
understand the position the United
Kingdom vaccine Network provided funding
of course for research and development
into vaccine Discovery and that of
course is why
the Oxford AstraZeneca vaccine was able
to benefit from the program because the
amount of funding that it had received
today all right
you've referred to the group think and
and and the group think has been
described variously as a flaws in
strategic thinking as perhaps a failure
to
to see things for for how they were
it may be suggested that there are a
number of ways in which there was group
think or a strategic failure
so the first one to which you've already
made reference is the long-standing bias
as it's been described by I think
Professor Dame Sally Davis and and
others in favor of influenza so so
that's the first would you agree yes
there was also second year a failure to
appreciate properly the risks
of a non-influenza pandemic
viral pandemics by their nature have
variable characteristics and variable
risks
and maybe High transmissible
they may have longer or shorter
incubation periods
they may be more or less deadly
would you agree that there was a failure
to appreciate properly the risks of a
non-influenza pandemic
I think
in deference to my scientific colleagues
they would all have said that those
risks existed but collectively we didn't
put anything like the time and effort
and energy into understanding those
dangers and I think if you look at the
the national risk register of 2017
it sort of says these are the two things
pandemic flu that could kill up to 750
000 or an emergency respiratory virus
that could cool up to 100. and that was
the assumption that collectively
including myself we didn't Challenge and
that is why my third
proposition is that there was a
strategic failure
to approach the risks of new and
emerging respiratory viruses
on the basis that it was necessary to
identify multiple scenarios not just to
focus on the one hand on
pandemic influenza with its terrible
assumed consequences and on the other
a much more limited generic
non-influenza pandemic scenario without
regard to what the specifics
characteristics may be
yes I mean I think we have to be
realistic you can't as a government
prepare for every single scenario
exhaustively so you have to make choices
as to which are the most likely
scenarios that you're going to have to
deal with but with the benefit of
hindsight I should try not to use that
phrase too often
um you know if you look at MERS in 2015
if you look at SARS you can see evidence
of these viruses actually taking hold
and
we didn't ask the searching questions as
to whether you could have
um whether we should be doing more
preparations for one of those viruses
becoming more contagious even than the
mers turned out to be in in South Korea
and other places but it's not about
hindsight is it because Chancellor is
you accept and if everybody says it very
very fairly
there was a failure at the time to ask
the more searching questions that were
required to be asked
correct
and the fourth strategic failure which
is more connected with the response
to covid is that because the reasonable
worst case scenario Doctrine
planned for the realistic worst
that might that could happen and made
assumptions as to the number of deaths
this tended to prevent debate and
thought about what might be done to
prevent those catastrophic consequences
ensuing in the first place
correct that is actually linked to the
kind of we should be worrying about flu
because yes flu has a as I understand it
a shorter incubation period is much more
transmissible it's much harder it
doesn't have that asymptomatic period
where but that that is why for example
in the whole of operation cygnus there
is no reference to testing
to quarantining those are not
things that we put any energy into I
would just add one other thing which we
did touch on earlier East Asia I think
there was a group think that we knew
this stuff best
and we there was a sense that um
we with perhaps the exception of the
United States there wasn't an enormous
amount we could learn from other
countries and certainly you know I I
didn't
this is with apologies this is with the
benefit of Einstein but I don't think
people were really registering
particularly career as a place that we
could learn from
um I think it's very notable career did
not have a lockdown in the first year of
the pandemic they avoided a lockdown at
all
and what I think is interesting is that
the reason that they had that superb
response I mean in the second half of
the pandemic quite a lot of East Asian
countries didn't do very well because
they didn't get their vaccines out as
quickly as we did here but in that first
year
I don't think there's any doubt that
places like Taiwan and Korea
did incredibly well but that was
actually because there was a lot of
public criticism of the Korean
government after the MERS
epidemic in I think 2014-15 when their
Laboratory Testing capacity was not up
to scratch they didn't have a network in
place and they they learned those
lessons and um
and and there was clearly a narrowness
of thinking of which you know I was part
which didn't think hard enough about
that kind of potential pandemic that
fifth I'd suggest strategic failure is
addressed at some lengthening or witness
statement and and
and to focus down on on what it was that
East Asian countries had because of
their MERS and SARS experiences thought
about planned for and debated
what was it that they had given
consideration to the funding of and the
the problems associated with
Mass testing
Mass contact tracing and mass quarantine
in essence
and as you say in your statement that
those were issues which we
as a country did not focus on
but the exercise Alice report which you
didn't see at the time
was based upon an assumed MERS outbreak
was it not
and the exercise Alice report at the
time 2016 made reference did it not to
the need for more learning
about Mass testing Mass contact tracing
Mass quarantine
so it's not a matter of hindsight is
there a chance that was a something that
was flagged up in respect of the East
Asian learning in the context of a MERS
exercise in 2016.
so no if I of course
bold I mean I think if you read exercise
Alice you can still see now obviously I
didn't read it at the time because it
wasn't shown to me but you can see that
there was still this underlying
assumption that you would be likely to
be dealing with something of limited
total number of fatalities in a hospital
setting essentially only indeed and if
you look at the recommendations I think
there were there were 12 and I think the
Department of Health social care thinks
that 11 were implemented and one wasn't
um
they
they didn't have the urgency
that you would have wanted knowing what
we went through just a few years later
so for example the PPE recommendation
it doesn't say we need to check that
we've got enough PPE it says having
enough PP and we may not have enough PPE
it says having enough PP is very
important
and we should do an instructional video
to make sure that everyone across the
whole system knows the importance of
having enough PPE
the reason that so I don't
believe that even if I had been shown
exercise Alice I would have necessarily
ask for things to have been done
differently
what I think is the reason it's
important it is literally the only thing
as we mentioned earlier that talks about
quarantining and the importance of
quarantining and if there was one thing
that could have slowed the progress of
covid when it actually arrived
it was to understand the importance of
early quarantining to stop the disease
spreading and to understand there are
types of pandemic where it is worth
putting a massive amount of effort into
slowing the spread and that we should
one of the very first questions we
should have been asking ourselves is is
this one of those pandemics that you can
actually slow and save lives early on or
not and and I don't think we had asked
those questions
but the reality was wasn't it Chancellor
that
those lessons or actions as they were
called in exercise Alice whether or not
they were brought your attention and and
you've said they weren't and there was
no evidence that Alice was ever brought
to your attention
the report itself identified a number of
actions which self-evidently were worthy
of further exploration that they were
the actions recommended by the very
report Itself by the exercise and the
actions focused on amongst other matters
Port of Entry screening
option plans for dealing with the cost
benefits and practicality of quarantine
versus self-isolation
plan for Mass communities sampling
and the development of live tools or
systems to collect data from infected
persons in order to be able to better
manage
testing and contact tracing so
regardless of of whether or not
ultimately
that would have been of assistance
when kovitz struck the fact remains that
to a large extent those particular
recommendations for whatever reason were
never carried forward to fruition
that's not my understanding but I think
it's obviously something for the inquiry
to get more details from from dhsc my
understanding is that they believe that
11 of the 12 recommendations were
implemented but I think you are right to
say that here was the one bit of all our
pandemic preparations where we were
closest to thinking about a covid style
uh
pandemic and it got very little
attention in the ground of scheme of
things
[Applause]
I believe that the quarantine options
paper in exercise Alice was
de-prioritized
and by the dhsc on the 28th of September
2016. so at least in relation to that
okay
nothing came of that
all right
or is that the one to which the
chancellor was referring that the
Department thinks wasn't implemented
it's not no the one I was thinking about
was
um NHS Communications
so I hadn't heard what Mr Keith just
said
so
may we take it that because exercise
Alice was not brought your attention
nor brought your attention was any of
the work done following exercise Alice
or any of the ways in which the various
actions recommended in exercise Alice
were not given effect to
correct I didn't know about exercise
Alice all right
going back to to the five strategic
flaws or aspects of group thing that
I've I've suggested to you
does your witness statement identify
that there are steps which may sensibly
be taken to challenge
group think
whether by way of
greater external challenge to challenge
Orthodoxy
or a greater awareness of
the events which have befallen other
countries and how they've responded
but also in in relation to improving the
the political structure
in relation to how planning is prepared
for
yes I mean I think there are lots of
things that we need to do
um
avoid that kind of group thing but I do
think it's important to say this was
pretty much the whole Western world that
was thinking this way about
um pandemics but
um the first thing I would say is that
um
you know in we we all discovered how
incredibly important Sage was in uh at
the start of covid and that's and that
is it's really important within Sage
that there is contrary thinking and
challenge going on
um and um I hope that Sage is structured
in a way to to make that possible
um I think that um
the other thing that I would say is that
if you look at the kind of the way
government works
curiously the kind of contrary thinking
tends to come from ministers who come in
with a bunch of experienced expert civil
servants highly professional
and ministers come in with their
priorities and the civil servants say
um we can't do that Secretary of State
for this reason or that reason
and so that's really where the most
creative discourse happens but what
failed here
was that of course ministers are not
scientists so the kind of challenge to
group think when there's a scientific
consensus
is never going to be done by a
politician in a in the most effective
way so when it comes to things like
scientific consensus you need to have
structures where you are welcoming
contrary thinkers and the Civil Service
tends to be a very consensus Driven body
and
um I know that I believe that you're not
able to use the Health and Social care
select committee's evidence as evidence
for your inquiry but if I could just put
on the record that I was extremely
struck when both Dominic Cummings and
Matt Hancock gave evidence to that
committee
that you know we said to them why didn't
you challenge this idea that you could
um you could stop the growth of a
pandemic that this this was somehow
inevitable and they both said it was
incredibly difficult with an enormous
amount of regret it was just really
really difficult to us to challenge a
deeply held consensus inside the system
so I think what I'm saying in rather
long-winded ways that
you need to have contrary thinking
amongst the experts you can't just rely
on it being the elected representatives
challenging the civil servants that has
its role but within expert bodies you
need to have that uh that challenge the
red team approach and so on it's not
always easy to get that though is it
Chancellor because I'm in another world
I used to be involved in criminal
justice
and it the number of times I saw a
theory developed within the medical
profession about the cause of injuries
or the cause of death or something and
if the person who propounded the theory
was sufficiently senior forceful and had
the personality to to carry the day
then it seemed that a lot of their
colleagues went along with them so how
do you make sure you get the experts
who'll do the challenging I I completely
agree and um
you know my father was in the Royal Navy
and in the military you have the same
thing where sometimes it's the most
Junior officer who actually has worked
out the solution to the problem but if
you have a rather overbearing General
they don't feel able to speak out so I
think you in areas like pandemic
preparedness precisely because it's so
difficult to see around corners what
might happen I think you have to have
structured challenge
one way or another in the systems and um
and I think that's you know I would say
um Sage is the most obvious place where
it's important to do that but but we
should think about that across
government Senator boy who said the
emperor's got no clues
and we can make life very difficult for
those little boys that's the truth
I hope you'll forgive me for verbaling
him I think Sir Mark warbot said at one
stage
that um the government Chief Scientific
Advisor was a licensed dissident
but but Chancellor from what you say
no committee
it would seem however diverse
experienced and wide-ranging in its
composition
it's going to be sufficient to be able
to address firstly the
mayor's nest of ministerial
accountability that appears to have been
developed from having a number of
ministerial positions dealing with
various different aspects of resilience
and and secondly the need for that
challenge to Orthodoxy to come from
outside government
so that it is listened to and also
politically it may be better enabled to
take or to recommend or advise difficult
funding decisions for consideration the
government of the day and therefore is
there not a case for
a senior cabinet minister with
responsibility for eprr to be appointed
who may have the ear of the Prime
Minister and also for an independent
resilience body to challenge Orthodoxy
and to provide guidance set strategy
organize exercises and report to
Parliament
um
there is possibly Samaritan that but I
would say that in my experience of the
Prime Minister I'd worked with
the most effective ones always surround
themselves with people who give them
completely honest challenge to any
course of action and I would say that's
a very important characteristic of
successful leadership in any field that
you are getting people who aren't afraid
to tell you that something you're
thinking of doing is a load of rubbish
that's quite a fundamental thing and it
doesn't always happen but I think there
is one other thing I would say that can
help so what we do have in this country
is a very Open Press
and uh very
um extensive and respected Academia
where there are lots of distant voices
and I think that if the sage advice to
ministers have been in the public domain
earlier in the pandemic
I think there would have been lots of um
constructive criticism from academic
organizations universities up and down
the country saying have we thought about
this have we thought about that which
could have informed Sage's thinking I
think they did come round
to thinking that actually the Korean
approach to a coronavirus is worth
serious consideration but
it didn't happen until May as far as I
can glean of 2020
and that in that period transmission had
increased to about 5000 a day
and then it was
inevitable that you were going to have
to use a lockdown had we got on the case
much earlier with that approach we might
have avoided that
coming back to your first point about
prime ministers in your experience
having a wide range of views in front of
them and of
advisors not hesitating to to speak
truth to power and to to challenge
Orthodoxy isn't the problem here that it
was the system
which failed to provide for a sufficient
degree of challenge
ministers
in their exalted status don't know
necessarily what's going on blur down in
the system there needs to be a body that
challenges Orthodoxy on the part of the
system itself it's not a prime
ministerial issue it's a structural
system
um when I was foreign secretary
um I discovered that my predecessor
William Hague
had instructed his officials as foreign
secretary that anytime there was a
disagreement inside the foreign office
about the right course of action with
respect to I don't know Iran or someone
like that he wanted to be told about the
disagreement
and I think that there is a strong sense
in the Civil Service that there's a
consent they need to come to a consensus
View and give ministers
a recommendation of a single course of
action and that makes challenging group
think harder
all right
can I ask you please about a specific
issue which is and you'll know from the
evidence as Christopher wormald the the
taking place of a departmental board
meeting in September of 2016 in the
Department of Health
it is
uh please at 57271
we need nothing trouble you with the
details of the departmental board
because Christopher is has given
information about what it consisted of
but this was these were the minutes of a
particular departmental board a very
senior
part of of your then Department which
was doing a deep dive
into major infection diseases and I paid
six please at paragraph 25 and 26.
you of the board from which
you are absent
was it was more likely than not that
even a moderate pandemic would overrun
the system at the extreme there would be
significant issues if it became
necessary to track all quarantine
thousands of people a decision to fund
and fund high-end quarantine facilities
had already been deferred by ministers
all decisions in response to an outbreak
or pandemic would need to be made by the
department of the Department of State
though arm's length bodies would have
their role to play there were however
concerns about how resilient the
somewhat fragmented system would be
especially in light of previous or
future funding cuts
the concerns expressed there
even in the context of a moderate
pandemic about tracking quarantining
how fragmented the system was appear now
perhaps with hindsight to have been
rather prescient
well as you mentioned I wasn't at that
board meeting and I've
checked as to why
and it was um and if you
you will have seen from the the first
page you showed up that there were
actually no politicians present at that
board meeting because it was three days
before the start of the Conservative
Party Conference and in fact
I was making my biggest single
announcement as health secretary uh
at on that third on that first day of
the conference which was the increase in
medical school training places by 25 so
there was a lot of work going on ahead
of that but I have subsequently read all
the minutes of that board and indeed the
presentation made by Helen Shirley quirk
and I think it there is nothing in there
that I wouldn't have known it was it was
a month before operation or exercise
cygnus I think that's why it was put on
the agenda
and my attitude would have been
yeah and and by the way the same
predisposition to worry about pandemic
flu and to worry less about respiratory
viruses I think is in the papers that
were presented to the board
um but
um my view would have been I'm about to
do exercise cygnus and which we will
deal with these issues exhaustively
all right
could I now turn please to the issue of
the resilience United Kingdom Health
structures which to which you've devoted
a considerable part of your your witness
statement
you
you make the point in your witness
statement that
the
NHS budget
um
was protected from some of the most
difficult elements to your words of of
the austerity period
and that in real terms Health funding
increased on a number of occasions not
least in November 15 when you secured an
overall increase in the NHS settlement
and again in 2018
but you make some observations about
how against
the quite separate and extremely
difficult issue of funding
something needs to be done about running
the NHS hot all the time
because of the obvious deleterious
consequences of doing so in terms of the
resilience of the health structures as a
whole and ultimately our country
how can one avoid having to run the NHS
hot
whilst at the same time
leaving funding questions open for
future politicians
I think it's
a very very important question to ask
so I became convinced during my time as
health secretary that the NHS needed
more capacity
um
it wasn't because I was thinking that I
had a crystal ball and I was thinking
there could be a pandemic around the
corner it was because I was dealing with
a winter crisis every year I was seeing
huge pressure in any departments I've
seen pressure on waiting lists
um and when I arrived as health
secretary there was a view that we would
need fewer and fewer hospital beds
because surgery was getting quicker and
a lot more day surgery you could
discharge people more quickly uh
pregnant mums could go home much more
quickly after they'd had their babies
and so on
um and and that changed when I was there
because I I thought that was more than
counterbalanced by the increase in older
people and uh the pressures caused by
demography
so I decided we we did need more
capacity
um and um I think the number of
employees went up by over a hundred
thousand during my time as health
secretary the number of doctors went up
by 17
000. but it didn't happen in a
structured way and I think that what we
need
in the NHS going forward is a much more
structured way of analyzing how many
doctors and nurses we're going to need
in 5 10 15 years time that that is for
the nhs's regular business when it comes
to the pandemic I think there's a very
specific
reason why that matters because
I think the NHS did extremely well in
the pandemic I think that you know the
the majority if not the vast majority of
uh covert people with covert who need an
intensive care Bear's got one
but we did so because we were able to do
what for example the German Health
Minister isn't able to do which is
through a centralized structure
switch off everything else and say we're
just going to focus the hundred thousand
beds we have on covid patients and make
sure that that is the priority
and when you read comments uh in the
papers about how good the NHS how well
prepared the NHS was for a pandemic
compared to other Health Systems I think
that's really what they were talking
about they were saying there was a
centralized structure that allowed you
to make big decisions from the center in
the way that other countries would not
be able to do with a more fragmented
Health Care system
but the price we paid for that was a big
Interruption to Cancer Care and other
treatments which is partly why we have
this big backlog that we're trying to
bring down now so I think you do have to
make a judgment about
you can't obviously build empty
hospitals in the you know to deal with
the pandemic that might happen around
the corner no country in the world could
afford to do that but you do need to
think about some latency in the capacity
and that was part of the reason why I
argued that we should have the big
funding increases that
I secured in 2015 and 2018. it does the
same analysis apply
to workforce planning in particular and
the the numbers of
NHS doctors and nurses you referring
your statement to the fact that
there have always been issues of course
with numbers of the NHS Workforce and
and with planning
and and you describe how
you became aware of the importance of
workforce planning
in the context of pandemic planning
is there any way in which you can have a
later capacity in terms of
sheer numbers
of NHS employees to be able to deal with
the contingent possibility of
of a catastrophic pandemic
I don't think any health care system can
plan to have as many doctors or nurses
as you would need in an extreme pandemic
situation just because of cost and also
because of the fact that you just don't
know what kind of situation you're going
to be dealing with indeed
um but I think that we should be better
at long-term workforce planning and I
did conclude as health secretary that
the structure we have because it takes
seven years to train a doctor
means that it's never given a high
enough priority in the system and when a
Chancellor in a health secretary are
negotiating a spending review settlement
uh
they're thinking about how we're going
to
relieve pressure in any departments this
year how we're going to have more Cancer
Treatments next year but the number of
doctors
coming on stream in eight or nine or ten
years time is inevitably further down
the priority list and you need to have
some mechanism to make sure that it it
always gets the priority it deserves
rather than what we have at the moment
which is a rather lumpy way of
increasing doctor's eye persuaded
Theresa May in 2016 I was very proud to
do so and we had a big increase then
but the first doctors from that decision
will be coming on stream next year so
that gives you an idea of the time
delays involved so is the start reality
that
an improvement in resilience
structurally walks and musk and can only
walk hand in hand with a general
Improvement in terms of Workforce
numbers and the health and the financing
of the NHS as a whole there is no
practical way of bifurcating the two
issues I think that
structured workforce planning
will make a very big difference to our
overall pandemic resilience yes
what about social care or any particular
adult adult social care you say in your
statement that one of your regrets as
sexual estate for Health and Social care
was that you're unable to secure a
longer term funding settlement for
social care or a long-term plan to
relieve pressures and iniquities in the
social care system
does the same analysis apply that an
improvement in resilience
must necessarily depend on Improvement
in the system as a whole and of course
that depends on on funding
um it does it's slightly more complex
because I don't think any country in the
world that I'm aware of has a
nationalized care system where all the
Care Homes are owned and provided by the
state
and so
I think all countries have a semi-public
semi-private system
again there were I think there was an
increase of over a hundred thousand in
the social care Workforce in my time as
as health secretary
but um I wanted there to be a long-term
plan for the social care sector I
negotiated a long-term plan for the NHS
with Theresa May and Philip Hammond in
2018 and was hoping to do so for the
social care sector and I think that was
next on their list too but then
unfortunately that government fell and
we had the pandemic and it didn't happen
when I became Chancellor in the Autumn
statement last year I did put through a
4.7 billion pound annual increase in the
social care budget because it was
it's unfinished business in my mind and
I hope that will make a difference
I would say that in Social care though
if I'm looking at Global best practice
and resilience I think the um
experience of MERS and SARS in in in
Korea and Taiwan I we I did look at what
they did with their Care Homes
and
I think I spoke to a professor from Hong
Kong University during the pandemic who
said that they had not had a single Care
Home death in Hong Kong
and uh there the key issue was not so
much the long-term plan by the way we
should do the long-term planning anyway
because it's very important for the
social care sector but that wasn't the
key issue the key issue is infection
prevention and control and the fact that
following MERS they'd said that every
care home had to have a named person
responsible for pandemic planning in the
care home and they very quickly stopped
external visitors going into Care Homes
to prevent infection being bought into
care homes from the community and I
think they were required to have a
supply of PPE as well permanently there
so I think and I think in Korea they had
some Care Homes where the staff were
asked to live on site at the peak of the
dangerous period to stop residents
getting infection so it was really
around I would say
the biggest difference we could make in
the social care system when it comes to
pandemic planning is that area
those latter issues are of course
matters which will be looked at in
Greater detail on the ladies later
module on social care
and finally the the topic of operation
yellowhammer
uh with which you'll be familiar
the emails and and the letters from the
Department of Health and Social care
when you were Secretary of State
make plain that following
that NSC thrc meeting to which
uh
you were referred earlier
that committee had put into place or
rather then prime minister had directed
the institution of the pandemic flu
Readiness program
and in the bundle as you're aware there
are a number of letters from yourself to
both Theresa May MP and
to to others
in in which you stress the the quote
the Vitality it is vital that this work
continues to be prioritized and
resourced by departments given the
significance and scale of the risk
so you were concerned to ensure that the
work ordered by that committee which is
the the work streams done by the
pandemic flu Readiness board B continued
to be prioritized
you you cease to become Secretary of
State on the 9th of July 2018 and
thereafter
the necessary preparations for a No Deal
exit intervened
and evidence has been heard by my lady
as two the extent of the interruption
and the impact of those necessary
preparations to what extent were you
aware once you had left that post a
sector state for
Health and Social care of the degree to
which the work that you had called to be
prioritized was being
affected
by the operation yellowhammer
I don't think I was aware at all
and is that because of course you were
foreign secretary I was foreign
secretary I mean I will say you know to
in answer to the broader question of
because the brexit vote happened when I
was Health secretary how does it impact
my my work as health secretary
um it was really a one
very specific thing I was concerned
about the future of our life science
Industry so I spent a lot more time than
I had previously visiting life science
companies in this country and around the
world because I wanted to protect our
ongoing life science investment so I did
spend time on that but um I
I don't recall ever hearing that
pandemic preparedness had been
de-prioritized when I became foreign
secretary
um Milady those are all the questions I
have for the chancellor I may ask you
please for permission to publish the
Chancellor's witness statement yes and
uh
standing Direction yes anybody indicates
for some reason it shouldn't be
published and then there are as as I can
see my lady you're alive too
two requests to ask uh questions from
the Corp participants under rule 10-4
covert bereaved covid-19 brief having
suggested UK and Northern Ireland and
the trade
trades Union fungus thank you
first Mr Weatherby and then Mr Jacobs
thank you
uh Mr Hunt
um
I ask
um a very few questions on behalf of the
Kobe Brie families for justice which
represents the interests of many Berry
families across the UK
um
just picking up from my Mr Keith left
off with
capacity and resilience
particularly nursing resilience and
Staffing levels were you aware that the
Welsh government
brought in place in 2016
legislation providing for nursing
staffing levels Health boards and NHS
trusts in in Wales during the relevant
period
no
um but um
I
what happened was that and this mail may
not be connected to that
um
we had a terrible Scandal of bid staffs
and we in England
had a very radical overhaul of of
Hospital regulation and we introduced
offsted rating for all hospitals and so
on yes and uh the Welsh government were
asked what they were going to do in
response to this because there were some
issues in Welsh hospitals I believe that
might have been their response I I think
it was to have regard to the importance
of providing appropriate numbers of
nurses in in all settings is that
something that you ever considered
um given Staffing levels in in England
is that anything you considered bringing
in in terms of England I thought it was
extremely important to have appropriate
Staffing levels I think the number of
nurses increased by 24 000 During the
period that I was Health secretary
my the main focus of my time as health
sector was patient safety and I was very
aware as to how Staffing levels
would have a impact on patient safety
and I did look at whether one way to
address this was to mandate Staffing
levels but I think the in the end the
problem with that approach is that you
could only mandate Staffing levels if
you actually have the doctors and nurses
to mandate it and that's why you need a
long-term yeah Workforce plan to make
sure you have the ability to do that if
you have Staffing levels then you've got
something to work up to though
well if you mandate it so I did look at
whether you should simply say it's a
requirement for example that you know
there should be one nurse for every
patients on a dementia Ward
if you make that a legal requirement
then the hospitals will have to pull
those nurses from somewhere else and if
those other areas matter then you would
cause damage to patients in those other
areas so that's why I didn't believe it
was an option yes until we increased
training you mentioned a couple of times
the number of nurses a number of doctors
that that you put in place but yesterday
the inquiry heard powerful evidence from
Professor Davis the chief medical
officer who worked closely with you
and she described the disinvestment her
word in the NHS as affecting resilience
and the UK being at the bottom of the
table
in regards to the numbers of doctors and
nurses with comparative countries
so isn't that a powerful argument why
there should be minimum levels of of
doctors and nurses probably other things
as well but it's not a powerful argument
for that it's a powerful argument to
increase the numbers of doctors and
nurses so you can put those
those levels in place safe starting
levels and i would support that I I
wouldn't use the word disinvestment
because
um
I mean in my time I think the investment
the NHS budget went up from 101 billion
to 124 billion but do we need greater
Workforce capacity absolutely we do yeah
I I think the point was the bottom of
the table in terms of comparative
countries in terms of those numbers well
I think if you
I don't want to suggest that we have got
to the right place when it comes to
workforce planning I think we need to go
further but I think the latest figures
I've seen out of the 38 oecd countries
were fifth in terms of the proportion of
GDP we invest in health so I think in
the period since 2010
we've grown but I think we can do better
when it comes to workforce planning
similar second Point similar
um similar point though that um the
inquiry is going to hear evidence from
the chair of the BMA British Medical
Association UK Council professor
bamfield
and in his statement to the inquiry he
indicates that the BMA regularly raised
concerns with governments in relation in
relation to the state of Public Health
and Health Care Systems and their lack
of capacity and resilience
um and the bmas communications ensured
that government were fully aware
that the public health and health
systems were struggling to provide
adequate Services even in normal times
um and that action needed needed to be
taken and then no doubt when he comes to
give evidence he'll he'll be able to
show the documents and reports he's
referring to but during your period
um in in the period running up to the
um pandemic when you were in office do
you recall those persistent concerns
being raised by the BMA and the
government's funding was insufficient to
sustain the NHS very much so because
there was a junior doctor strike that
lasted nearly a year and it was
because I was trying to that the
immediate cause of the strike was my
request that we should have
um better weekend Staffing at hospitals
because I thought that matter for
patient safety
but in the course of that strike
I was trying to understand why it became
such a bitter and long strike
doctors were saying you're asking us to
work more on Saturdays but we don't have
enough doctors in the week yeah and I
looked at the evidence and I thought
they had a point and that was why
um I introduced a 25 increase in doctor
training places in October 2016 followed
instantly by a 25 increase in nurse and
midwife training places
it isn't the real answer to these issues
that insufficient consideration is being
given and needs now to be given
to long-term sustainable funding for the
NHS to bring its resilience up and to
ensure long-term that there is
sufficient doctors nurses and other
resources for business as usual but also
to be able to play a full part in in
emergency shocks
I don't think you can fairly say that
there weren't big increases in the
clinical Workforce
during either the time I was Health
secretary or even the broader period
since 2010 but what I would say is that
I don't think it happened in a
structured way
that it should have and I think it'd be
much better if it was done not because
of particular Health secretary at a
particular moment takes an interest in
it but because there's a long-term plan
which includes thinking about resilience
yeah as to how many doctors you're going
to need in in five different minimum
long-term standards with proper funding
um transparent so everybody can see yes
but just for the avoidance of doubt I
think it is important to say that the
funding levels did go up significantly
and we do fund at comparable levels to
other European countries thank you Mr
Hunt
thank you very much Mr Weatherby I said
Mr Jacobs but I can't see him
to the back of the room
um my lady well there you are
I may be obscured from you but I think I
can see um the chancellor
um good afternoon Chancellor I have just
a few questions on behalf of the Trade
union Congress
Chancellor could I start with a an
answer that you gave just a few moments
ago to Mr Weatherby
and your evidence that in terms of
spending on the NHS as a proportion of
GDP
um the UK or the NHS features
um fifth I think you said amongst the 38
oecd countries
when looking at NHS spend as a
proportion of GDP currently
does that in reality reflect at least in
part not so much an increase in funding
but our GDP falling behind or our growth
in GDP falling behind our peer countries
I don't believe so because we've grown
up broadly the same rate as Germany
since
2010 I think our GDP growth rate has you
know some years it's up and some years
it's down but
we've our GDP has actually grown faster
than France and Japan since then so I
don't believe that's the reason
Chancellor you you pick um Germany is
Germany not the sole other G7 country
um that has a broadly similar GDB growth
or lack of it
um than the other G7 countries for
example no I think we grow we grew
faster if you're talking about since
2010 as a baseline we've grown faster
than uh
focusing on on on recent developments so
during the course of the pandemic
well
if you're talking about
we spend fifth out of 38 countries uh
that uh that's that's where we are today
um and as I say in terms of recent GDP
growth over the last decade I think I
I'm not sure I
um I think the point I would say is I
think what you might be saying is could
we have gone up that League table quite
a lot
because of growth in the last couple of
years
because of a lack of growth over the
last couple of years is that the
question well Chancellor let's look at
it a slightly different way given that
we are focusing on the NHS as we go into
a pandemic at the beginning of it
it is it you've said where we are today
but is it right that in the decade or so
leading to the pandemic we generally
lagged behind peer countries in terms of
spending on the NHS as a proportion of
GDP
well I just remember when I was asked
that question as as health secretary
many times I seem to remember that we
were generally bang on the Western
European average and the oecd average
During the period hours Health secretary
I don't have the exact figures in front
of me but I think we were broadly at the
average level
however we compared I think your
evidence a few moments ago was that in
your time as Secretary of State for
health and Secretary of State for Health
and Social care you did become convinced
of a need for more capacity within the
NHS is that is that right correct
and one of the matters you describe in
your statement is that after operation
sickness in 2016 you agreed that both
the NHS and social care system were
fragile and in need of more funding is
that right correct
and in response to that
um there was
an announced
um increase in funding in June 2018
that's when the announcement was is that
right there was also an earlier
announcement in
October 2015 or December 25th towards
the end of 2015 but the bigger
announcement was then yes yes so the
bigger announcement June 2018 and is it
right to say that that related to an
increase in funding over five years that
was to start in 2019-2020
um
either 2019-20 or 2018-19
okay
um do you think it's correct to say
Chancellor that realistically
um that funding would have been too
close to the pandemic to address the
fragility in the NHS that you were
concerned about in 2016.
well it's I think the way to put it is
as I mentioned earlier to to Mr Keith
when I arrived the NHS budget was 101
billion when I left it was 124 billion
that was negotiation for an additional
33 billion
yes I that that might be an answer to a
slightly different question my question
was
um you're concerned about fragility in
2016 the funding increase comes in I
don't think you can quite recall but it
the 2019-2020 tax year do you agree with
the this the simple point that that was
too late to address the fragility which
you yourself were concerned about
I don't think so because
look I accept your broad point that I
think there needed to be more capacity
that I think the system the Health and
Social care system were fragile
but I also recognize that as a country
we had very fragile finances in in
2010 following the global financial
crisis and
um we had to do some work in order to
get ourselves in a position where we
could afford the big increase that I
negotiated in 2018 so I don't think it
would have been possible to negotiate
that in that increase any earlier
because I don't think the funding
existed to do so
I'm
one final matter a Chancellor
um we heard yesterday from Dame Sally
Davies she was your chief medical
officer wasn't she throughout your time
as Secretary of State for health and for
Health and Social care
you describe her in your statement don't
you as your excellent chief medical
officer is that right
yes
and what she said yesterday and Mr
Weatherby touched on a part of it she
describes not having resilience in the
NHS and by comparator data compared to
similar countries per 100 000 population
we were at the bottom of the table on
number of doctors number of nurses
number of beds number of itus number of
respirators number of ventilators
um
is that a picture you recognize and do
you think it's a pretty damning picture
of the state and capacity of the NHS as
we went into the pandemic
it's a picture I recognize and I try to
do something about with big increases in
doctor nurse a midwife training places
with big increases in the NHS budget so
that we would be able to afford to
employ them
so yes that is exactly what I thought I
thought the NHS needed more capacity to
increase the
the doctors ahead to to closer to
Western European levels but the context
that that was the NHS that the
government inherited and there was also
a financial crisis so it was going to
take some time in order to address those
issues but do I agree with Ames tally
that we need to approve improve our
capacity in those areas absolutely yes
Chancellor thank you thank you melody
milady
uh covid-19 bereave families of Justice
camera have emailed in to say that they
have been thoroughly introduced by my
failure to ask a question that they were
told uh I would ask and therefore they
seek your permission for me to put the
question that wasn't put
may I have your permission to do so
certainly Chancellor did you have
communications with the Welsh ministers
for health
in connection with pandemic preparedness
and preparation
and
how effective were the systems of
communication were they as effective as
they could have been and if not how
could they have been improved it
described itself as a single question it
may not be no I think in it's probably
um in response to a a negative comment
in the papers from the the then Welsh
Health Minister about his lack of
Engagement with me as as health
secretary Mr Vaughn getting correct
um and and the answer was that
they were quite strange relations
because
um
the Welsh government response with the
NHS was Labor
the Scottish NHS was under the control
of the SMP
and I was the English Health secretary
and I was responsible and I was
obviously conservative
and
the reason and that doesn't mean to say
you can't have cordial relations with
people from different parties but in
this particular case the NHS was the
central Battleground in every general
election and so in every general
election there was a narrative that
labor would say here
the NHS is in a terrible State we would
say it's in an even worse state in Wales
and
and this is not the place obviously
getting the Rights and Wrongs of those
claims but they were the claims that
were made so we didn't have uh very good
relations I fully accept that for the
sake of pandemic preparedness what was
my strategy my strategy was uh that we
needed to have the best possible
relations at an official level
um and I think that actually that was
one of the positives that came out of
exercise cygnus that the chief medical
officers for the four nations did
develop a network and actually I think
that was something that worked pretty
well during the pandemic as well
I think I should observe
Chancellor that
given that the etymology of this issue
was Mr Vaughn getting that in his
witness statement to milady's inquiry he
says in the context of exercise sickness
Jeremy Hunt was the United Kingdom
government Health secretary although he
was I think present for the opening of
the ministerial engagement element of
the exercise he was absent for the
second day at a junior UK Health
Minister took the chair and he says this
my impression was that UK ministers did
not take ministers and officials from
the devolved government seriously
has your evidence been in fact that you
were present on that day when
the decision had to be made by the
de facto Secretary of State in that
exercise to make decisions about triage
to which you've referred and so you were
very much part of that exercise I was
there for the first day
um I think in its entirety but
um
as I say I was conscious of the
political challenges of close
cooperation given the context we were in
and so my Approach was always that we
should nurture the closest possible
relationship at an official level
where those political Rivals didn't
exist thank you
very much use the evidence for today
Chancellor thank you very much indeed I
hope you haven't taken up too much of
your time thank you for your
thoughtfulness
10 o'clock tomorrow thank you